[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is going on everybody hey if you
can hear me if you can see me
give me a little thumbs up in the chat
uh lots of setup on this one lots of
lots of good technical setup we got some
help sodamonte behind the scenes
setting everything up for us
uh we get we got william foshee you know
and i might have i might be butchering
the last name a little bit um he's
joining us today we're going to be
creating awesome stuff in unreal engine
um
yes he is compiling shaders at the
moment uh
so uh we are going to be creating
a
industrial scene because that's this
week's weekly challenge prompt and we're
going to do it
uh
probably in like two hours or so we're
gonna see what we can do in unreal
engine
but um sweet we got some thumbs ups it's
good to see y'all it's been a minute
uh it's been a minute since i've
streamed and i am so glad
that i am joined by such a wonderful
guest let's let's switch over let's see
what's going on
william what's up
it's going very well it is going very
well
man thank you so much for joining me
this is such a treat and such an honor
to have you on the stream um
your tutorials are my favorite they're
so good they're so freaking good
oh thanks so much i appreciate it
yeah absolutely
so for
for people who don't
know
uh william
puts together the best unreal engine
tutorials on youtube in my opinion like
there's a lot of great ones out there um
but over the last like three months i
discovered your youtube channel and
it's absolutely
absolutely incredible let me let me just
see like
i'm gonna pull it up here to show people
um william how did how did you get into
3d and vfx how long ago was it for you
uh i'd say with about i think it goes
all the way back to something like
274-75 or something i was very young i
was just a kid and you know obviously
like most you know early teen you know
big into gaming love video games and you
know it was at that time where like hey
i want to make games and how do you do
that you know i'm in high school and you
know i'm sure you probably had this in
school but we have like these
orientation
courses where you meet up with someone
like hey like you know what do you want
to do when you grow up and you get older
where you want to go to college that
sort of thing so i told them hey i want
to make video games and they're just
they basically just laughed at me
they're like oh you can't do that you
have to be an engineer or a doctor or a
dentist or whatever
um
and
you know how it is right like they're
trying to encourage people to go to
higher education and you know at the
time i want to be a concert artist i
love drawing painting that sort of thing
and they said like oh no like they're
content that's not a thing
um so you know when i was maybe 14 or
something i found what was like a it was
a book at the bookstore uh called
introduction to maya 4.5 or something it
was a really really old version of maya
and
that was kind of my entry into 3d that's
kind of what where i discovered you know
what a vertice was what polygons are and
how to you know i pretty much fried my
parents computer at the time with that
um because they just had a typical
family computer that was not made for
doing 3d at all um and that was kind of
my first glimpse into 3d um
and i just really i loved it i really
enjoyed it and i've always been pretty
artistic throughout my whole life where
like i said earlier i was into drawing
painting
so you know 3d was kind of like a
natural transition into
um
into just furthering my art
i guess and uh loved it ever since and
so fortunately
uh there was a school in my hometown
that specialized in game art
and so you know i signed up it got
accepted uh it was a one-year program
but it was a for-profit school and it
was it was really a bad school it was
pretty terrible where um
so to this day i prefer to say that i'm
self-taught um
but same technically
it's yeah it was that bad
uh so it was the type of school where
they just they charged an exorbitant
amount of money and the teachers were
basically former students that they
hired
so like oh hey you graduated from our
school do you want to teach it's like
so uh that's kind of how that went so
you you can expect
you get an idea of how that turned out
so not the
a question we get all the time is do you
have to go to school
to work in the 3d vfx industry do you
need a degree
absolutely not no um like i said i'm
pretty much self-taught i learned most
of what i know today um either on the
job or uh online with the internet like
now especially nowadays there is more
content
than i know to do with like there is so
much amazing free content online
nowadays it's just absolutely amazing
whether it's youtube where you can find
stuff on gumroad or
you know like now even like unreal now
has awesome documentation uh they have
their own courses as well like so they
have unreal online learning so they're
making their own courses as well to
teach you how to use unreal um but long
story short no you do not need a degree
but i would say it depends on the person
i think some people learn really well
under that academic you know having that
academic pressure on them so if you're
um it can really help to
uh to go to school and have someone push
you have a mentor push you in the right
direction and on top of that you have
the added benefit of getting
um you know you get the networking as
well you you're just there's pros and
cons to both so if you don't have
you know the money for it then that's
okay you don't need a degree to get a
job in cg you really don't man that's so
true that's literally exactly what i say
it's like school is good for people who
need the like structure and who want to
meet contacts
yeah um not that you can't do that on
your own
um
you just
i guess would need to have a little bit
more self-motivation to push yourself to
agreed to do it but here's the thing
like all of us here like i would assume
that most of us here on this stream
are here because we love
doing 3d we love we love doing
visual effects we love
being creative and
the hobby
and the spark is already there you know
yeah
um so just roll with it you know like
for everyone out there who's just having
a blast keep having a blast keep loving
it you know and
these streams and you know this
both of our channels right are geared
towards helping people
uh learn and grow and get inspired and
not get stuck
when they're having to troubleshoot
stuff because troubleshooting is
part of the job right i mean that's kind
of what i actually that's what sets
really like good artists from great
artists i think someone who knows how to
solve problems and as a quick
troubleshooter um that's where they
really stand out and so you can be you
don't have to be the best artist in the
whole world to get a job you just need
how to you need to two things you need
to be able to problem solve quickly
and come up with solutions quickly and b
also know how to deal with people
because i've met amazing artists like
some of the best artists i know but they
just they they have to work alone
they're basically low in wolves they
cannot work as a team because they just
they're complete jerks basically um and
i'm sorry you're gonna especially in an
industry where
you have to work with other people you
need to know how to deal with other
people uh so
and the industry is really small so
don't be a dick because it's going to
bite you in the butt um it's it's it's
really as simple as that
yeah 100 and i mean just don't be a dick
regardless you know no for sure for sure
be a good person uh and that's why like
i mean man just just meeting you and
chatting with you
since
the last video i did the last breakdown
i did um i was on your channel
constantly learning stuff you helped me
out so much with that and then like even
person to person you're like hey you
know here's some
here's some secret console commands try
these i was like oh my god this is the
good stuff thank you so much
you're you're a great guy you're very
nice man and it like it goes a long way
yeah no one's gonna gonna hang out with
people who are just stingy and
you know jaded and all that all that
stuff but um we have we have so many
questions and we have we have art to
make today um but before we get into all
of that good stuff i am so excited uh
for today's sponsor it's amd and you all
just hang tight i'm going to tell you a
little bit about them and we'll be right
back we'll ask more questions
uh to william we got uh people we got
community questions and we got art to
make so back in just a second hang tight
today's stream is brought to you by amd
the leader in processor technology for
3d and vfx artists whether you're
creating 3d worlds in unreal engine
blender or cinema 4d or compositing
complex vfx shots in after effects or
fusion a high grade processor will only
make your life easier and your 3d vfx
workflows smoother so your cpu is
measured by three main attributes you
have cores clock speed and threads cores
are essentially the workers assigned to
computational tasks
clock speed is a measure of how fast
those workers work and threads basically
determine how many tasks each worker can
complete at once
certain 3d tasks are considered lightly
threaded like animation simulation and
modeling and benefit from a high clock
speed whereas other tasks like rendering
or editing high-res footage utilize all
the cores and threads your cpu has and
amd's threadripper pro series offers a
wide range of chips to balance these
workflows now i recently upgraded my
workstation and specifically went for
the amd ryzen threadripper
3970x could not be happier chips like
these are an investment no doubt but
will greatly increase your productivity
and output so click the link in the
description to check out amd's chips and
consider them for your next upgrade
all right all right yeah check out that
link in the description very good stuff
uh no joke i i do have an amd processor
and i love it um they make really solid
stuff very very solid stuff i have a
video coming out in a couple weeks here
basically right on thanksgiving weekend
going into how to build a computer
all the parts that go into a computer um
and things to look out for when you're
building one so it's actually a perfect
sponsor really excited to have them um
but uh yeah let's jump back in so i'm on
uh williams art station right now and
i just want to show you a little bit of
his work like this stuff is incredible
he's got tutorials for all of this stuff
man they're so they're so good and uh
god dang this is ridiculous
this is absolutely ridiculous so for the
record this is not an unreal this would
render it in arnold so it is an offline
renderer so it's not real time just uh
just making that clear
this is amazing
very very beautiful
so you started in games and then
transitioned to vfx is that that's
correct yeah so i yeah so for the first
five or so years of my career i started
in games so it's a small indie studio in
montreal and uh great learning
experience um and then but like you know
after five years i think i kind of
outgrew the place
and actually at that point right when i
left the games industry i was kind of
on the cusp of just quitting 3d
entirely i would fed up i was like okay
tired of the crunch i'm like okay i'm
done went traveling for three four
months came back and then you know how
it is like i got that zbrush itch that
just kind of came back like oh i kind of
want to uh it's nice to get paid to
sculpt stuff all day uh i do miss that
so then you know kind of got back into
it into game for another year or so and
then i went traveling again
and after that i kind of made my way
into vfx i was trying to find a job
abroad i wanted to leave montreal
because i grew up about two hours of
montreal but spent most of my adult life
in montreal and then i you know found a
job in in norway which is where i live
now
and it just so happened this was from
for a vfx studio called storm studios
and
they needed someone with unreal
experience
uh for a project that they had so they
were doing this kind of like half vfx
half game half real time type of thing
yeah um
and so like it was a perfect job for me
like it was kind of my way into vfx and
because i think it can be a little bit
hard to break into vfx when you only
have a game's background because the bar
quality that you need is just that much
higher in film um as opposed to games
so uh so unfortunately that was my kind
of my way in and so we worked on that
project for about a year and then
they just kind of kept me on and we
started working on i think my first film
i worked on with black panther so that
was um that was fun that was a great
yeah it was a really that was a great
learning experience as well and so
then i stayed at storm for another five
years or so and i would say that those
five years have been the greatest
learning experience of my entire career
like working in film
um like i said it really raises that bar
of quality
and it just
because people are just like nitpicking
pixel peeping your frames and every
single frame of your renders constantly
every single day and you meet up it's
just it's a very different
um
it's not harder or easier it's just it's
a very different
level of quality that you need to attain
and so people are really nitpicking like
hey like these pixels are kind of you
know you got to fix that or fix this and
i've always been a bit of a generalist
so i've been you know i started off
working in like i said in game but doing
modeling texturing uh in zsx like they
they realize that i'm able to do you
know modeling texturing looked as and
for those who don't know what lookdev is
it stands for look development so
basically doing shading like all the
more complex shader networks and
lighting as well did a bit of animation
so i kind of done a bit of everything
and then even threw me into comp at one
point
doing compositing work and again
awesome expert learning experience
because i love you know tearing apart
and figuring out like okay how do people
do this how do people achieve this kind
of result and
eventually you kind of realize how all
those pieces of the puzzle fit together
in a nice little
package and that's kind of that's the
whole spirit of the effect that it's
there's not just so much more than just
you know lighting and nice models it's
just the the compositing the colorist
work that goes on top of that after the
editing the music the whole package and
so
um yeah like so i've always been very
passionate about just art in general and
i've kind of been like a one-man army so
to speak so yeah same you know
especially coming from
from games and now going into film
the direction that unreal is going in
now like those two worlds are converging
and it really has helped having a
background in games really helped me you
know make sense of unreal because i've
been using unreal since 2008 or
something so um that's crazy man
it was not what it is today i'll just
leave it at that like to that so in 2008
it would have been
unreal engine 3 and after that it like
the udk came out so udk meaning like
unreal development kit
and back then like you could dynamic
lighting was not really a thing i mean
it kind of was but it looked terrible
and uh and then you had the bake
lighting for everything and that was
that was a time consuming process so
um the
has come so far in the past
three or four years alone it's it's not
even close to what it used to be so
things are easier than ever to use um
still has its quirks as i'm sure you
found out when you were working on your
thing oh my goodness man i i it's such
like a love hate thing because
oh
i i i it's so complicated sometimes is
that the program is ridiculously
complicated and there's so many things
like if
my goodness i probably only know
one percent of the program
like i mean there's so much to it
it started off in the game engine
and yeah i don't think the developers in
their wildest dreams ever expected
unreal to be used on like feature films
like it is now
um i i don't think they ever expected
unreal to be used on the set of the
mandalorian for example
no not not when no there's no way it's
like it's a game it's it's for making
games
yeah and
but now
everyone realizes like
and i think you i'm sure you
paid are paving the way for this is like
all of your stuff here
making unreal cinematic this video right
here is so good it's so good like you
get in you get into all of it and you go
through like
what makes it cinematic you go through
frame rate you go through all the stuff
and it's like
you're paving the way for this kind of
for this kind of stuff and for these
people who want
their art to look
like a movie and not
like like a game you know um
it's hard to do in a game engine it's
it's not the thing that there's a lot of
like you said like there's a lot of
things that are just complicated um
i wouldn't say complicated is the wrong
word i think the better word is
unconventional um i think they did
things in a way that made sense for the
developers at the time
but they i mean i don't know i wasn't
working at epic so i'm not going to
presume but my guess might you know
uneducated guess is
i don't think they had any like film or
vfx artist on you know
on on their on staff right so they just
kind of did what made sense then for
them and but that's like that's not how
we do it in film like
stuff like there's so many things like
that uh regular passes for example like
i mean now we're starting to get object
ids and stuff which is cool but there's
still so many things like uh like why
why why why
yeah absolutely absolutely um so you
know that
that's an interesting topic because we
actually do have a question from 3d gala
on
the discord server and
they're asking
will there be a more
i mean i'll read a verbatim will unreal
engine become more artist-friendly and
have a non-game dev version in the
future at the moment a lot of things
unreal are extremely complicated tedious
to do or just crowded and i'm guessing
this is because unreal was created for
game dev yes um
i mean what do you think
i think that's a bit of a learn
i have two answers to that so i think
there's a bit of a learning curve with
any application ever like when you when
you're used to working in one program
and you kind of shift over to something
new there's going to be a learning curve
and the things that were so easy for
example when i went from 3ds max to maya
because in 3ds max is what we use in
games and archviz
um and then when i work with that
sorry to cut you off are you you got
unreal open
i do all right let's switch over
cool
so uh yeah so when you have
when you have um
like three when you're used to its
program like i was working with 3ds max
and then went over into maya
there are so many things in mind i was
just like what what the crap like what
is this this makes no sense this is
stupid um it was so much easier in 3ds
max and so it there's a learning curve
right the process of uh you have to get
used to a different way of thinking
there's a new philosophy there's a whole
design philosophy different between from
one app to another you go from maya to
blender
again i i can't i tried picking a
blender and i just couldn't because
navigation is all weird and like just
getting used to the uh you know rotating
handing around the camera with the
middle mouse key it's like
yeah i equate it to like
someone breaks into your house and
goes through all your crap and puts them
in different drawers and like yeah it
even shifts the rooms around it you wake
up in the kitchen you're like what the
heck
where am i this is my this is my kitchen
but i went to bed in my bedroom and like
you start going okay i guess i'll take a
shower and then like you know your
towels are
stuffed under your under like your car
in the driveway or something you're like
i don't know where anything is i know
what i want to do but i don't know where
anything is
no that's exactly it and it's super
frustrating at first because like ah
and like so that kind of brings my next
point so yes there's a learning curve a
lot of things are really complicated and
unreal um but i think a lot of that has
to do with the fact that like you gotta
relearn a new application like that just
regardless of what tool you use there's
going to be that
painful process of relearning how to
walk
and i give it usually it takes me about
a week like one week of dedicated
production work you can pick up any tool
of course you might not be you're not
going to be like the best but you'll at
least be able to walk you're going to be
able to create something within a week
because you start like
crawling you start at a crawl you know
and you're just i can't move i can't
move but then you know you look up
everything on youtube you got your stuff
on youtube look it up and like there's
just tutorials for everything and yes so
you get to the point where you're
walking and then what
and then and after that then there's
also the fact that there are i'm not
gonna lie like i love unreal but there
are a lot of things that are very
unconventional there's things that just
are done a certain way in film
and if you for a film artist to come
into unreal they're just like what is
this why is this all like this um things
like you know just dealing with alembic
files
um it's gotten a lot better now
but you know it for a while like alembic
was just totally broken uh it barely
worked and things didn't shade properly
or deformed properly and it's just
really really annoying
and then there's the whole rendering
aspect because it's kind of
it's real time so at least sequencer was
almost more like a of a
sequencer like so
you use dude sequencer right so yeah
yeah sequencer basically it's unreal's
kind of timeline and everything so
um it's where you know you're going to
trigger all your events is where you're
going to set up your keyframes and
everything we're going to load your
animations and sequencer would
essentially if you wanted to render out
those frame render out your shot you
would have to it would essentially
package the whole thing and play an
executable game and screen record that
and so
that's essentially what's happening it's
doing like play and editor mode it's
creating an executable thing in a new
window and it's recording that at the
desired resolution
and it's
it's fine it works great and it looks
great it's real time it's quick and
snappy but the problem is because of the
the real-time nature of things
you're never going to get the exact same
render twice
so you know this is just a complete like
messes up your brain for any of the
effects orders for anyone working from
offline renderers to this because an
offline renderer is if you have the same
settings same everything you hit the
render button you're going to get the
same render twice yeah um and that's
that's super important because sometimes
you know they want to make just a change
to the lighting and not to change the
geo and those matte like this is really
important for compositors with masks and
stuff because
um you know they need those edges to be
perfect every single time
but in unreal it's going to be slightly
different because there's like temporal
anti-aliasing on that so there's like
that jitteriness so your edges are
always going to be kind of messed up and
this is kind of a pain for um
for compositors right so
there's a lot of things like that that
are just really
yeah like i said unconventional and so
to kind of segue back into the question
um
i don't work for epic so i can't say if
there's going to be like a non-game dev
version in the future i think the good
thing now is that epic is aware that
there's a massive demand for you know
offline rendering stuff or you know i
know it's real time but you know there's
a lot of people using this for you know
on film sets and stuff so there's a
whole other user base that they never i
don't think they ever anticipated to
have
using unreal now so maybe hopefully
they'll cater to people
um
using unreal for that purpose yeah
hopefully because it's i mean yeah it
was on they use it for mandalorian like
the whole virtual wall stuff is going up
so like
it'd be cool i don't i don't know like
maybe
who knows maybe it'd be like da vinci
where there's like a color
color tab a
cut tab a delivery tab and like you can
go into film or i mean they have like
the templates at the beginning when you
start your project file but
isn't that just like
toggling on certain plugins
essentially yeah i mean that's that's
pretty much that's pretty much it yeah
um so i i hope that they have yeah i
would love to see like a more like a
streamline like
just rendering only part of unreal um
but you know
it i have no idea what they plan on
doing and
from what i've seen in ue5 like things
are more or less exactly the same as in
ue4 like the the the way you work is
pretty much the same
uh that hasn't really changed that much
it's definitely were you using um ub5 or
when in your project there i was using
four in that last project i did that
music video um that was unreal four i'm
in unreal five right now and man i gotta
say like
it's so much easier to get
things looking beautiful
because it just happens immediately
whereas oh yeah like unreal 4
you have to kind of like
do everything manually you have to add
everything manually but it's not it's
not a bad thing like you certainly learn
how it's built and how it's composed um
like global illumination the bounce
lighting all the ray traced all
everything but in in unreal five like
that stuff happens automatically and
it's so
satisfying to like oh sure the lighting
i mean lighting a lumen alone is just so
awesome
uh it's really great to get that that
kind of just easy like but you don't
have to think about it it's crazy like
they bounce light on this it's like
it's insane
for a shower oh man it's like it gets me
so excited because
i love the idea of i mean it's kind of
like the ian hubert approach where you
have photo scans and
they look pretty darn real
and you combine that so ian obviously
isn't blender
um
but i would love to
kind of
test out that approach in unreal
drop in a bunch of photo scans i'm doing
a lot of phone photo scanning these days
and like
you know just with unreal five the
lighting is perfect everything just
looks so nice and
you
like the more you can create without
troubleshooting the better
you're gonna have to troubleshoot no
matter what
but like the future the the goal is to
get rid of
all the googling
all the searching
all the digging through menus and you
just want to like close your eyes and
see what you're
seeing in your head and put it onto the
screen as fast as possible and have it
look as good as possible
and yeah i
yeah i was just saying like unreal five
like
it's it's exciting it's exciting for
sure it's definitely like i haven't even
been using ue5 that much myself i've
been in ue4 purely for performance
reasons
um
and just what i'm doing with clients
like they need uh
uh what's the words like they needed
things to be
more stable like they can't really
afford to
to to
just to have the latest and greatest
tool they need something that's reliable
like just a reliable workhorse right
yeah for sure for sure so
that's why like ue4 is just kind of the
way to go for now
um
and i i'm just uncomfortable in you
before i have no issues with it and uh
like i've already troubleshooted all
those issues like there's no more or not
much googling for me at this point yeah
right so um so i gotta gotten like all
that
junk out of the way um but i i've had to
learn that the hard way like it wasn't
an easy thing to do
it was uh
you know all my tutorials all of them or
the vast majority of them like all those
like small issues like that the field
issues and all the like the small little
bug the fog all that stuff those are all
things that i had to find out the hard
way
when i had a project due in three hours
and my renders were coming through right
um i've been there it's uh i know what
it's like so i i figured i was a bit
reluctant at first to um
what's what the word to you know to tell
the whole world about all these things
people think hey like i kind of learned
all these things myself um i want to
kind of keep this to myself like this is
you know it's my my hard work oh really
interesting yeah okay that was my that
was my first reaction this one this was
before i made my channel right yeah and
then you know um
and then slowly about a month or two
before i made my channel a former vfx
supervisor of mine asked me to make a
course
um like hey you know we know you know
unreal so would you like to um
to make a
ah what's the word would you like to
make a chorus on unreal and world
building in general i'm like yeah sure
why not so that was kind of you know it
was a paid gig and so that's kind of
what made me
get like the microphone get the webcam
get the whole thing set up and so i got
that out of the way and then you know i
had all the equipment and i figured like
hey why don't i maybe i'll try this
youtube thing just for just for fun
and uh then i started had my first
stream had my first video go out and you
know it it
grew relatively quickly
amazing and that's when i realized like
hey like if i don't share this all these
tips to the world um someone else is so
i might as well take credit for it so
there we go
[Laughter]
that's awesome that's great yeah and i'm
glad i'm so glad and we all are that you
have shared that with us because
ah man it's it's so good it's so good um
quick shout outs are due we got visual
we got ronin sotomonte of course
we got mdk up in here all the moderators
from the discord server are hanging out
with us uh it's a good time it's a nice
little reunion it's been a minute
since i live stream william and i'm
really happy that that uh you know
you're my first guest back into the live
streams um
you know i i slowed down i posted a
video maybe a month or so ago
talking about how
i need to slow down um
because i'm burning out i gotta
i gotta
have i gotta you know like like i said
i'm going rock climbing after this for
like yep nine hours straight i can't
wait it's gonna be awesome like oh man
it's a good day you know we get to make
some art together and then i get to go
rock climbing i just need more balance
in my life so
it helps to slow down a bit how's your
workout man are you crunched like crazy
are you are you
going on full steam ahead or are you
taking breaks uh you have hobbies that
you do or anything
it was um it was it's been a rough year
uh so you know i started a youtube
channel last december so it's been a lit
almost a year not quite it'll be a year
in uh in early december
and so i was doing that i was pumping
out one video every week plus a
full-time job and then
you know plus a few like consultation
gigs on top of that as well and then you
know
just in the spring i realized like hey
you know i think i can try going
full-time freelance yeah and uh just
because i've been working for someone
else for
too long
and i figured like hey nick now now the
time i think i i have this opportunity
you know with youtube going well
um i'm just gonna give it a shot i'm
gonna take a bet on myself for a change
and uh
fingers crossed and just like what's the
worst that can happen right and yeah so
uh so i i quit my job and started
going freelance
and so that's been kind of my my main
thing for since the summer
as of july and it's just it's been busy
it's been it's been good it's a good
problem to have i can't complain
and um
but like i've been doing like making
courses for epic i've been teaching as
well i've been youtube has kind of taken
the back burner just because
um like i was doing one video every week
but now like you know i've been there
just too much to do and i'm like okay
you know what i need to prioritize and
uh i was already working you know
60 70 80 hours a week um so i'm like
okay i think youtube's gonna take a i'll
i'll pump out one video a month instead
of one a week
so uh yeah that's like kind of what i'm
doing i'm like i gotta i gotta do one a
month i could do one a month um
your last video was great by the way the
little like uh how to save a bunch of
gigs on your hard drive
blew my mind like that was just
something i saw on twitter i'm like wait
what that that's a thing
yeah i did that absolutely no idea
yeah
good times for sure
but so um but yeah sorry go ahead well i
was just gonna say i'm gonna tell
everybody what we're doing so um
for those of you who don't know which is
probably all of you because i didn't i
didn't say it yet um
so what we're doing today is uh we're
we're doing the weekly challenge prompt
it's industrial so we're both creating
whatever industrial means to us uh we're
creating that on the stream and we the
goal is to get it done before we're done
uh before the stream is up
cool i probably will probably go to like
two o'clock at the latest you know so we
have we have we have a good chunk of
time here to hang out and create art
together so
um that's what we're doing yeah the
weekly challenge um is available to
anyone to everyone there's a discord
link in the description and uh it's not
the entire discord server
um but it is the weekly challenge help
channel a general channel um and if you
win the weekly challenge then it unlocks
the whole discord for you uh for one
week
and it's like everything even the
patreon stuff everything gets opened up
completely
um
obviously you know
we're doing this like we can't win the
our own contest here but we're going to
have some fun and we're going to create
some cool stuff so
uh william you have any idea of what
you're going to create for this
industrial
um probably some i kind of want to go
for a
like kind of a kind of a like a typical
industrial look but something like more
cleaner
a bit of a cleaner industrial look like
i don't know if you i mean surely you
you know peter mckinnon right oh yeah
so uh his photos are i mean he's a great
photographer i love his stuff and he
kind of has this kind of like clean
grungy but clean look like really high
contrast punchy
uh photos and i kind of kind of go for
something like like he does there i can
probably
show it on my screen
maybe if i find something on his
instagram or something but yeah he's a
great photographer i love his stuff
um
super passionate guy
yeah he he's great man i
i watched his like um
i think he he's got a video or two on
like either going through all the stuff
in a studio like a little studio
overview i'll switch to you full screen
here um okay cool yeah yeah he has like
a studio overview and like where his
lights are how he sets up his mic and
i'm like that stuff is so valuable to me
because like i'm constantly trying to
iterate on my setup here you know i'm
trying to mount some lights to the
ceiling i'm trying to get a
you know a little little shotgun mic a
directional mic instead of this thing
because i can't see my keyboard
you know i can feel you
yeah
i just love this stuff it's it's so
simple it's nothing fancy but it's like
it's dark with these like
hard um you know hard highlights on them
like really high contrast
stuff looks great so i'm going to try
and kind of go for that kind of style um
probably just like some kind of parking
lot or some kind of garage or something
cool pickup truck in there
and uh yeah i usually try to wing it
like most of my projects are i just i
don't really
i would like to say that i'm super well
organized and i start off you know
really elaborate planning and like
concept art and everything and truth is
i don't um i'm really i'm really really
bad at that kind of stuff i'm really bad
at planning um most of my projects like
just knowing myself i'll start something
and
it's pretty rare i see it through
because i'll get bored or just be like
oh just you know what i'm just gonna
um just do something else but it's not
good it's not a good thing i'm not
condoning this i actually like encourage
people to finish their project as much
as possible because that is how you
learn that is the it doesn't matter if
you have like 50 starter projects
because you haven't learned how to
finish a thing right like it's so
important to see a thing through to
completion um so it i i encourage people
to do that and like i'm but you know i'm
the worst following my own advice so
you know how it is
yeah it's so true i i have a few
projects that are unfinished on my
computer absolutely i'm always tr i'm
always like working on two or three
things at once um
yeah
you know um
so like in a way
certainly yeah certainly and i
you know i think life getting in the way
is a good thing though it can be a good
thing because sure it's always balanced
you know like i will constantly be in a
state of like trying to find balance for
the rest of my life like i know that i
will always be balancing things um
that's hard do you have any advice for
people who like who do have a struggle
between like a work-life balance and
stuff
well shoot man i struggle with it and uh
don't we all yeah like
what what what do i do i well okay so
here here's something i learned at uh at
camp mograph which if you don't know
about it everyone should look it up
can't mograph
i mean i'm gonna be there next year it's
the greatest thing ever basically is
that what johnson win bush or
yeah win bush was there um
okay ever i mean beeple was there uh ej
was there
yeah yeah uh ashland was there man it
was the sickest thing ever oh my god
it's like all of us out in
an actual campground
for five days just hanging out
and like talking and creating stuff and
there were zip lines archery
uh
rock climbing
there was a lake like man it was the
best but the point i was trying to make
is that
there was a guy there a speaker is
austin something he's a designer and i
apologize i don't remember his last name
but he said
there
is
what was it paraphrasing here he said
something along the lines of um
there's
there's
time that's always for sale there's time
that is sometimes for sale and there's
time that's never for sale
right and that was like so good for me
and i was like how do i implement that
into my life
and
for me uh
i basically blocked out my day into
three chunks and i know that i'm not
gonna hit this every day i'm not gonna
be perfect every day but if i can aim
for this it'll be great so like the
first chunk of my day
is spent
like either mental mental or or physical
so like a workout
bike ride a run
um meditation yoga
tea you know anything that isn't work
like don't
don't walk into this room before 10
o'clock but as soon as 10 o'clock hits
i'm in here
i'm working
till six
and once that's done once six o'clock
hits and it's hanging out with the
fiance watching tv cooking go for
another walk
um
and those are like
that's how i am balancing my life right
now um right
and you know over the last week
or two
it's worked out i like it you know i i i
am a workaholic i know that i i will sit
here and work
to the end of time
and i will die and rot and be a skeleton
in this chair i know that
so i have to force myself
it's tough
i get that i mean it's one of those
things where like you know
working for another working for a studio
it's one thing like everyone hates
working overtime everyone hates crunch
and i'm one of those people but the
thing is it's different when you're
working for yourself because it's you
know it's your thing it's your job it's
your work it's your clients finally
right
you're making
uh
middlemen right and so it's so easy to
just spend too much time in your office
and i'm super guilty of this like i was
very guilty of this this summer um
you know like my girlfriend she was you
know she had the summer vacation off and
i was like yeah sorry i've got to work
so
um yeah well i didn't even take any
vacation this summer so it was just like
work work work um so probably not the
the healthiest thing but sometimes
there's a time and place for it
sometimes it just has to be done
um especially if you're just
just starting a new company like you
kind of have to put in those
those hours at first it did the initial
little crunch and then
you need to know when to back off
um
yeah agreed you know starting running a
youtube channel you got to keep the
videos coming
you know it's like you do
yeah you do and that's uh i try to be
careful about that because at some point
like you know especially with smaller
channels like youtube doesn't pay that
much like it doesn't cover all my bills
so it's like i have to prioritize like
okay like what is the priority here um
can i justify spending you know x amount
of hours a month on youtube um but of
course like the more time you do spend
making content on youtube the more money
you get so
it's kind of it's it's it's never enough
right so it's never going to be enough
and i think we need to realize that as
creators like hey like it's okay to take
one for yourself just relax
yeah it's so stressful though it's like
oh my my life depends on this if i don't
make money then i'm
i'm gonna die
it's like yeah oh
like you're not it's gonna work out like
life has the way of working itself out
um
and i'm probably way too privileged uh
to be able to say that so i should
probably not say more about that but my
point is
life does have a way of working itself
out and just
you're not going to lose all your
clients if you take a weekend off is
what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah 100 man
so if
yeah
it's okay to take a breather
man when i when i was uh
i went on a yoga trip to bali
okay and
we uh
you know bali is it's not a a very rich
place um there is some pretty intense
poverty in bali and we right
the the person who is running like the
the yoga
um
you know
uh
trip essentially we're all learning and
learning to do that stuff
they were like hey we i have some
friends in bali um they know some people
who need some stuff like we're gonna
bring rice coffee and eggs
and we went to three like
of
the
poorest places that i've ever seen in my
life and
this one family in particular oh my god
this one oh so rough
we show up man and like
they all come out of this like brick
cement
square
and it's just dark and there's a one cot
in the back corner like you can barely
see it it's just like in the shadow
and they all come out and it's like
grandma mom dad four or five kids and
like one of them is mentally challenged
and like they're they're they're
having a very rough time and we bring
them these things and like the grandma
like starts breaking down and starts
crying but i can't handle this dude i
can't
it it broke me man and like oh
see seeing that but they were all happy
like they all they're all smiling and
stuff and they were like just down for
the eggs and the coffee and the rice
they're like thank you so much this is
awesome
right and
like any time i think like oh man it's
like it's not going my way it's not it's
like man they
had it rough and they were happy in
their situation like as rough as that is
they could find the happiness in that
situation i'm like i can't complain i
cannot complain ever about
anything dude i'm sitting behind a
computer i'm live streaming with you
like this is this is nuts we're creating
art and like
yeah it's part of our careers like we're
so so freaking fortunate and so lucky so
i mean to everybody out there who's
who's doing the same like
you know count your blessings for sure
for sure i mean we i mean i i i've got a
good i can't complain either it's uh
like you say like i i'm in a good i'm
lucky that you know i'm able to do what
i do now from the come from my home like
i've for a long time like when i was
working uh at storm like
um in oslo i would have to commute for
like four hours a day because the train
it was a two hour train ride each way
right and that was like that was uh
that was an interesting
year so i did that for a year about a
year and a half or something yeah and uh
i'm like yeah i don't really want to do
that ever again because that's that's
you know almost
20 or so hours of your
week is just on a train just commuting
um so that's
it's a lot of time and just time that
you're never going to get back i'm like
i'm doing this to go to work like
why
so
um yeah so like since working from home
it's just like when when kobe hit um you
know we all kind of worked from home and
let me oh this is i re that was kind of
what made me want to go freelance as
well because now i never need to answer
to a boss ever again i just kind of
do what i want yeah it's nice and that
that freedom is worth so much gold
yeah
um shout outs here to jurassic ham for
the super chat much appreciated says
love the videos i'm a 2d concept artist
recently got into blender to try and mix
3d in with my digital painting and i'm
loving it sun heck yeah that's great
it's so much fun keep that spark going
it's such a blast to be able to create
um
and get better at something so that you
can just keep creating
and get to the point where you know
we're talking about walking through the
program how about flying through the
program that's that's gonna be sweet
when you can fly through any program and
just create what you see in your head so
keep it up keep it up thank you for the
super chat and perfect xero i see you as
well much appreciated thank you for the
super chat it's very kind of you
hope you all are enjoying the stream and
having a good time hanging out with us
because i know i am it's a good time
how's your uh how's your art going
what's what's going on on your side
getting there getting there aren't you
trying to set up some materials and
stuff like that if the boring stuff at
first right the kind of thing you got to
get out of the way and this is one of
the things like sitting on landscape
materials it's just oh
there's a lot of things i wish that were
just quicker and easier landscapes are
one of those things where just setting
up i wish like how do you use um rvt yet
like render runtime virtual texturing no
i don't even know what that is
so i'll i'll be able to show you once i
get this set up and it's essentially the
ability to have objects automatically
blend with the landscape so you get like
that nice transition there's no hard
edge but you know when you when you
smash a cube and a sphere together you
get that hard edge between them right
yeah um where that geo intersects with
runtime virtual texturing you don't get
that you get a nice perfect blending of
one material into the next one
and it's awesome it's just a nightmare
to set up
so
there's a way of simplifying it which
like there's a lot of you know people
selling auto materials and stuff so they
make that process a whole lot easier um
but yeah you just need to set it up at
first and then it's
it's so painful
um i'm on your screen right now so if
you want to just you know kind of
talk people through what you're doing um
yeah
that's uh that's exactly what i'm doing
now so i'm just trying to find right now
i've got this kind of dirt um
landscape texture on it just some dirt
and mud or whatever and i'm gonna change
that i'm gonna i wanna make this more of
a uh like concrete floor and stuff and
the reason i'm using a landscape instead
of the static mesh it's just so that i
can get that runtime virtual texture and
get that blending if i want to put some
rubble and stuff you know dust will
blend and it'll blend into the concrete
a bit more uh smoothly you're not going
to get those those hard edges so i'm not
even sure how it's going to look but
it's definitely something i want to try
out so i'm just looking through my mega
scan materials right now
and finding let's say concrete or
something and
yeah something some kind of
something i can use on um on the ground
for the most part
and like this maybe yeah there we go
grab that
just dragging my
maps there
it's like it's that part of the process
that's super boring it's it's like it's
not it's not right
it's chill man we're hanging out we're
just chilling
yeah i'm looking through
i'm not doing anything
any more uh exciting i'm just looking
through like
quixl assets right now
yep yep i mean that's that's it's kind
of part of probably i think it's chill
it's like the the time where i can
actually put music on normally and just
uh just not think too much that's why
i'm able to talk easily and just kind of
do my thing because sometimes as you get
grow later into the process sometimes
like you you know you're you're focused
and you you're i can't do two things at
once i'm like
i'm struggling and
it's like there are times where i can't
even have music on because the music is
too distracting right dude i feel the
same way like with uh
even it's weird this is weird okay but
like with rotoscoping okay um you know
oh yeah effects and i'm rotoscoping and
i'm like listening to a podcast and i'm
like i can't even listen to this podcast
i
i i'm here i'm weird though cause i love
rotoscoping
mm-hmm and
maybe i don't love it but i
i'm totally cool with it and i welcome
anytime i need to rotoscope because it
is like uh
like meditation you're focusing on one
task and like you're getting it perfect
and it looks beautiful
um then you play it back and it works
out but yeah sometimes it's just like i
can't even listen to podcasts because i
want to do a good job
um i totally get that it's i don't know
why like i wish i could just like you
know just not think so hard but i find
it just so distracting i'm like i can't
focus on two things at once here i need
to like just do my thing
um so like i have to like i'll often
have headphones on all day but like
there's nothing playing
oh yeah yeah yeah
that'll happen to me as well for sure
i'll forget i have them on
except when they start getting like your
ears start getting greasy and you're
like oh yeah this
oh never thought of having
greasy ears but you're totally right oh
man it's rough
uh brian
brian uh caffano
i really appreciate that super chat is
very very kind of you sir it says keep
up the work uh
i'm a vfx lighting artist looking for an
internship right now even though i use
maya nuke your tutorials still help me
so much you and my teacher monica from
academic phoenix revitalized my love for
art heck yeah that's amazing wow keep it
up keep going keep creating cool stuff
and uh
you know you'll you'll find you'll find
some work
do you have any any advice
for people looking for work how do you
find
freelance work
as a vfx artist or 3d artist
it's a very good question i think that's
that's the turn that is the excellent
question um
in my case like since starting my
youtube channel that's been probably
been the best
career decision i've ever made like
there's so many more opportunities that
have opened up thanks to it um but
before that i think the best thing to do
is just to have a good portfolio just
show the world that what you're able to
do and get your work out there and
obviously the whole you know apply for
jobs and stuff obviously that kind of
goes without saying um but it's really
important to have a good reel a good
well i say real but just a good
portfolio in general like i don't even
have a real um i don't think i've ever
made one i i just
it's only recently that i've sort of
semi enjoyed making videos
before like a year or two ago i hated
making videos hated it the process of
whole video editing was just terrible uh
no bueno
did not like it at all um it's gotten
better like now i'm like okay i think
things it's okay but previously like
many years ago i just could not stand
the thought of making videos so um i was
more of a portfolio guy had like had an
art station page and just just make art
just be
the best you can be and keep learning
and you know it's just networking is
probably the most important thing in the
industry because it is a small industry
um
small place everyone knows each other uh
so it's just
so important to not
you know alienate the wrong people yeah
and like like i was saying earlier right
just don't don't be a jerk uh obviously
that goes without saying but it's even
when you reach out to people like risk
reach out to people in a professional
way like i can't tell you how many
people like they'll try and they'll send
me a dm on instagram
and like hey william and you know it
they go into my like message request and
i don't always see them right because
you know did it pile up and i rarely
checked that yeah and then you know two
days later to be like oh i see you're
ignoring me okay thanks i'm like
it's like this is not gonna do you any
favor dude like this is not that kind of
passive aggressive attitude is just not
going to do you any good in this
industry like someone knows someone um
sorry everyone kind of knows
someone in the industry right so you
know if you piss off the wrong person uh
you're not gonna find any work
yeah it's not gonna be good going back
to just being a good person
yeah for sure just reply like right in a
professional way don't just don't hit
someone up like you're their best friend
uh like hey bro what's up like hey just
maybe like
write something up a bit more
professional than hey bro uh for a first
message once you're more familiar with
with someone than that that's fine and i
say hebrew all the time but just not to
potential clients is what i'm saying
that's a good writing
just like just being able to write a
coherent sentence
uh write a good email like you know have
it as
you know just
yeah stay professional it's just it's as
simple as that that having a good
portfolio making good art that's that's
the key
because you're not without the art
without the good work you're not going
to get hired
no unfortunately like you can be
you know the nicest person in the world
but you you just have to have the work
to be able to show that work right so
you got to do the job you know like yeah
first question is can you do the job
second question is are you chill
and then that's kind of
that's kind of it you know um
there's probably other things like are
you close by but that doesn't really
seem to be that matter is less and less
now that's yeah that's one one of the
few
great things to come out of koben and
the cove had been a terrible thing for
everyone involved it's been awful
uh but one of the few good things to
happen
from kobit is the
general acceptance of work from home
like more and more studios are generally
like more open to the idea because my
former um workplace
they were
adamantly added fervently against any
kind of remote work and that was just
the
oh man it was really frustrating because
like i told you i had a four-hour
commute to work every day i would get up
at five in the morning every day catch a
train for two hours
and get to work at eight so you know i
would wake up at five you know get ready
for work and everything i'd be at work
at eight and until four and then four
take two hours of train back i wouldn't
be home before six or seven at night
depending if i had to you know work a
bit of overtime one night even if it's
just 30 minutes well like cool i'm gonna
be home 30 minutes later then already
late
um so i was i was for work i had to be
away from home for 12 to 13 hours a day
and that's just
yeah it's awful
exactly and so i would ask my boss like
hey like
is there any possibility i can work from
home or something and
he would just like no no it can't do it
at the time they had a
somewhat of a justifiable reason and
that reason was
uh you know like security right like
they had like disney level uh security
clearance and you know we had clients we
disney was one of our clients so i
understand
the security aspect of things
um
so that i'm like okay you know what fair
enough
um but then covet hit
and
and then like everyone were working from
home like did all the disney like i
almost working for every major studio
working from home security they would
globally accept it like okay you can
remote in now and despite that
my foreign bots were just like no we
can't no you can't remote so we're like
well what what yeah it was very very
weird so that's kind of roughly when i
left for another job that was very okay
with remoting yeah and that alone like
that right there just saved me you know
four hours a day
so uh
it was so much better
yeah i read a book
as soon as like the pandemic hit me all
had to work from home i read a book
called remote and uh yes i have two oh
yeah it's so good i'm like
going into an office is stupid what are
we doing
um and then
you know like
it's frustrating because you're like i
can do my job from home why do i have to
come in i i love working from home
personally i get to be
my fiance like i get to go on walks i
get to go to a coffee shop if i want
like i do whatever
freedom you know you just have a bit of
freedom
yep so
it's nice i enjoy yeah i i got i heard
from that book i think it went from ash
dorp i think he suggested at some point
oh yeah and uh i'd on a podcast at some
point and i'm like yeah no it was just
i mean it's just
it's so much better i like like you i
love working from home um
i live out in the countryside so like
it's so nice to just go out for walks in
the morning before work and just start
working you know whatever time i want
there like i'm i have a really bad case
of add uh i was diagnosed with a kid so
like going to school school was tough at
least you knew and
what the i said at least you knew as a
kid
uh yeah i guess so like my parents were
very concerned um you know just because
like my grades never really held up at
first and they're like hey like you know
what's going on so they figured out
early enough that it was uh add and so
the reason i'm talking about it just
because sometimes there's times of the
day where like i can't focus like if i i
i don't very really do well with a
typical nine to five
um
just because
well it's just
you know there's going to be times like
at eight or nine like i'm not productive
right now i'm just not going to get that
much work done it's just that's just the
way it is and um yeah that's that i mean
i
i have adhd
i i learned very basically um and like
there there's par part of me feels like
not to discount anything because i
literally have it
i i wonder how many aspects of adhd
everyone else has that doesn't have adhd
sure because like
burning out mentally and like not being
able to focus on like mentally
uh
draining tasks after like four to five
hours
that that's just
standard like you're not gonna be able
to focus you just
you know burn burnt out for four to five
hours you you you redlined and like you
can't how are you expected to like do
anything productive after that
and
i wonder you know like is that
just adhd or is that everybody
yeah it's hard to say right because like
if not to you don't want to say like oh
my life is harder for me than it is for
you right you can't like
you can't know
yeah
yeah it's it's tough but
i don't know i'm constantly like my mind
is it's weird my my version of it is
like i i i am somehow able to hyper
focus
on what i'm doing and i can't like tap
out i i i i'm just so zoned in i'm
tunnel i get tunnel vision really hard
um there are times when i get distracted
um like
i hadn't made any progress on this art
since i started
you know because like it's hard to talk
and do this at the same time
but you know you get distracted and and
all that stuff and i dude i forget
everything i forget oh shame oh it's so
annoying i have the memory of a goldfish
short-term memory goldfish but long-term
memory man i'll i'm like an elephant
like i'll remember what someone was
wearing
20 years ago i'm like oh yeah you're
you're like the red t-shirt dude wait
what
nuts man but but short-term memory
though it's like it's really bad i i
have notes everywhere like sticky notes
and post-it notes like all over my
office i see like that physical tangible
um like i have a dry erase board right
next to my desk because like i if i
remember okay i have to do this thing i
have to write it down or i will forget
it they're just it's just going to
happen
dude
same way man i got my freaking notes
here of like what do i have to do before
the stream what do i have to do after
the stream and then i have all these
notes like sticky notes everywhere
across my desk and everything
yeah it's it's annoying man i'll like
i'll forget my phone in my car i'll come
home i'll come home and then i'll like
where did i put my keys god dang it
oh
same i ate my key the key thing was so
bad for me that i had to uh buy those
apple ear tags
yep and so every every single time like
i'm leaving the house i'm like okay open
up the app okay keys are there found
them
man i'm the same every time i'm the same
way
uh we got some super chats here to shout
out so we have let's see let's see
bj hey it's been a minute man thank you
so much
for the very generous super chat that is
awesome of you good to see you again you
said in the past few months you've been
working with blender now i'm also
learning unreal engine it's great any
suggestions on
what render engine is best
for unreal uh we'll get to that in just
a second
and because we got one or two more
super chats
uh to shout out i don't want to miss
anybody drew drew a drew annan so drew
is actually
uh an old old old friend that worked
with us when i was at uh working with
freddy uh on his channel freddyw before
rocket jump
um
so good to see ya shout outs
thank you guys for being so inspiring
and helping all of us be better in the
virtual production space it's very kind
of you thank you drew i appreciate you
man
um and then i think we have one or two
more
uh guitar jams
what's up you guys are amazing at your
crafts but did you have any adversity
with yourself or with family about being
an artist for a living it seems like you
need confidence to push into
the
dark until first client
um let's start with that and we'll work
our way back up to vj's question so did
you have any
adversity you were mentioning some
adversity like you can't do that as a
job but that was from this
what was that from the school oh yeah
that was absolutely from the school well
not the school but um
like the the orienteering
people okay yeah the people who helped
you try to decide where your college and
yeah what yeah exactly so i don't i
wasn't sure what you guys called it
to
over
there
you can't do that
it's
i don't think they explici
encourage the idea they like that
they're the kind of people who
they would 100 push any kind of high
education job so like like i said
engineering and being a doctor
pharmacist or uh whatever
and they
never ever ever pushed for you know
manual labor like i had a good friend of
mine like he knew he wanted to work
construction when he was like five years
old
and he went and so you know he just it
just made sense like if you knew him he
was like yeah he's gonna be a
construction worker that's that much is
obvious that's awesome and uh but those
you know career helper people they're
just like oh yeah no you can't do that
you have to be like a civil engineer
he's like no
i don't want to be a civil engineer like
i know what i want to do like stop
telling me um that i need to go to
college or whatever uh because college
is not for everyone don't get me wrong
i'm i fully encourage you know higher
education it's i'm sure it's a great
experience um but it's not for everyone
right like we need manual worker we need
manual labor we need plumbers we need
electricians um so like i don't know
what it was a very weird push
um encouraging student to just
not do manual labor it was is that the
same thing over in the u.s do you feel
uh
man i'm trying to just think of my
experience uh
like
um
in terms of being
like
told not to do art i i never had that
i was lucky enough that my parents were
like down for
you know for what i was really into
i mean to let to let your kid at 19
years old
no no no i was 21.
i think i was 21. i was either 19 or 21.
but i'm i drove from georgia to
california to like move out that's uh
that's how you can drive
it's not yeah it's it's not it's not a
uh
it's not a small drive um no
no it is not it's like
36 hours i think
um damn yeah that's uh that's that's
not short
but
yeah you know like i i went to a tech
school and the the tech school i i
actually dropped out i went about a year
and a year and a half or so and it was
after effects photoshop and all that
stuff and like right you know people
were into it but honestly i from youtube
from andrew kramer and from grayscale
gorilla i knew how to
do all that stuff before
i went to school so i'm like this is a
waste what what am i doing
and like i've told the story a couple
times but like my teacher my after
effects teacher mr mason he's legit he
was like
you have an opportunity to go out to la
and
your dad won't let you go
why don't you just tell them that you
can always come back if it doesn't work
out and that right you're going to
school so that you can get a job
and you're saying you got the job before
you finish so
why would you finish school
um and like my dad was always like no
you can't drop out
i don't i don't care if you go and
do the art i just need you to get that
degree
because that's how he did it and then
like
right i told him that i was like mr
mason
told me this and like he thought mr
mason was cool because he let me work on
my youtube videos in class and stuff and
like okay he was like
okay
if that's what he said
okay
and like he was down he was down for it
so
i thought i'm really lucky i got really
lucky with it and like sure my dad was
cool enough to
let me do that but in terms of you know
i mean it's la everyone's creative here
everyone's doing like some
ridiculous thing that you know on their
own trying to make it happen for
themselves and like
yep i don't think there's any adversity
in la with
creative stuff so again very blessed
yeah it was the same for me i was very
lucky that my parents were super um
they were very encouraging like did they
just didn't really care what i was as
long as i was happy and so you know they
i do remember there were times like yeah
maybe consider something else i think i
wanted to be an archaeologist at the kid
right
and uh like an archaeologist oh dude
indiana jones yeah yeah man and so like
yeah i totally want to do that and the
parents like yeah like you know maybe
maybe consider something else or
something
um but yeah but in terms of art like
they were always very uh supportive when
it comes to art like i would yeah so i
can't complain about that
that's awesome
that's awesome
um
[Music]
uh john finger what's up dude we gotta
get some hacky sack it's been a minute
since we sacked out
that's very very kind of you thanks for
the super chat man
very good stuff i missed you on
halloween
i missed you on halloween dude i even
got the glow-in-the-dark hacky sack for
for that night but
thanks for the super chat thanks for
hopping in here man
um
all right so we got guitar jams drew
shout outs to drew vijay okay so vijay's
asking any suggestions on what render
engine is best for unreal engine
um and personally i'm like
the whole draw for me to unreal is the
real time
aspect of it um i know that i do have to
render my stuff out like i learned that
on that last project um but
yeah what are your thoughts on render
engines inside of unreal
like maybe render queue or something or
we tell him like
like like some people use octane in
unreal so is that what they mean you
think
maybe because under because unreal cell
is a razor is its own render engine it
is yeah 100
so i'm not so that's why i'm not totally
sure i understand that question
specifically um but you know i mean a
common question i get is often like hey
like ue5 or you before right um
and
it honestly they're kind of apart from a
few bells and whistles like lumen and
nanite
uh
they're more or less identical like the
ui is different color in ue5
and like i said ue5 has a few other new
tools which are awesome you know things
run a bit better um but fundamentally
they are identical but there there
really is no fundamental difference
between ue4 ue5 so if you start learning
ue4 you're going to transition real
nicely into uv5 that's going to be a
total non-issue
um so it doesn't really matter which one
you pick i think it all depends on what
your needs are if you just want to play
around and have fun and get some really
nice looking images ue5 is great because
you know if you don't depend on
stability um
lumen is so much easier to use
yeah yeah that was actually
a question from uh timeless plays on
discord i was asking like for someone
who's starting and wants to just do
cinematics and videos like
would you start an unreal four or five
and just grow with five as it you know
yeah they kind of have their pros and
cons right so in five you've got lumen
but there's no path tracer like i'm
using the path tracer right now um and
just because you know it's just it's the
easiest way to get great lighting
and that's only in ue 4.27 so you don't
you don't have that in uh in ue5 yet
it's going to come but ue5 is just
purely early access it's like beta
it's not a full release yet so i have a
lot of people asking me on youtube like
hey why are you still making ue4 content
ue5 without and then that's where
they're wrong uv5 is not out it's early
access
only
so it's uh there's still a ways to go
before
uh uv5 is like fully officially released
and when you say it's not out it's early
access
it is still available to everybody for
free yes yeah
um but what i mean so what what i mean
by that to specify is just it's kind of
beta it's just it's a lot of things that
are going to be changing and improving
and getting better it's a little bit
buggy sometimes it you know it walks out
for no reason
um
you know and it is much more performance
intensive you do need a better gpu uh i
think the the recommended specs on ue5
are much higher than they are in you
before so if you got you know if you're
running on a you know 1080 or something
or a 1070
maybe you stick with you before
interesting okay uh very very
interesting because like i said i'm
making a video on computers and like
specs and how to build stuff for for 3d
artists specifically and i was looking
at the specs and they said you need uh
for unreal eight gigabytes of uh video
ram on your gpu that's the minimum uh
yeah and which i mean most gpu have that
now yeah
yeah um but are you saying there's a
different recommendation for five or are
those uh five oh i mean so you know you
you probably saw like the the value of
the ancients uh playable the new tech
demo they released with ue5 yeah
yeah so that the the recommended specs
to run that is an rtx 2080 32 gigs of
ram
uh and the 2080 has like 12 gigs of vram
so that's their recommended specs so
it's it's like yeah it's not the minimum
you like you can run ue5 with lesser
specs that's
you can't i'm not saying you can't um
but you know to really push nanite to
its limits to really you know use lumen
fully
you're going to need a better gpu
so like in ue5 like i can never get any
scenes above
you know 30 fps ever
so um you're gonna have performance-wise
it's a lot easier in ue4 and what's nice
about ue forward you can migrate all the
projects over to ue5 when it comes out
so what you're doing now is not wasted
that's a very good point yeah it's a
very good point it is however there's a
caveat there
if you for in 427 right so i'm using 427
right now you cannot migrate 427 assets
into
ue5 early access
you can with 426.
interesting so that
so because i think 427 was never really
supposed to come out because kobe
delayed the release of ue5 and
everything so u426 was supposed to be
the last ue4 version uh but then uh you
know like i said everything got pushed
and delayed so they released 427 which
had a bunch of virtual production
upgrades updates and stuff stability
updates
new features that sort of thing um so
but because it's a new fork of the
branch the new branch or whatever i'm
not i don't i'm not an engineer um it's
basically a new build of the engine
that's not compatible with the early
access version of ue5 but
4.27 will be
you can migrate to ub5 once it is fully
released
okay got you so
very confusing i know
what you need to know is if you want to
migrate 427 to you revise early access
you can't you're going to need to
migrate from 426
to ue5 early access
so just something to keep in mind
william i have a question this is this
one's personal a personal uh
one here so
in in bridge i'm trying to
bring
an asset into
uh ue5
yep
and if you notice
in my
you can see my screen right
yep i can in my export settings up here
there is no ue5 option
okay um oh you don't need
i'm glad you asked that that's a
fantastic uh little tip there with uma5
you don't need to use bridge it's built
into ue5
close that close that junk you don't
want to do that so open up your content
browser
uh i know you have it you have it hidden
there i think yeah yeah there you go so
you'll see on the top left of your
content browser you see add
and then up there there is add pixel
assets i think
and it's going to open up the bridge in
the editor oh
dude that's a game changer
oh my god
yeah it's one of those things that like
it's not immediately like obvious
dude
wait so it doesn't have my favorites
am i logged in
i've decided i'm sure the favorite
transition over i have to say um i think
that's why hold on okay that might be
why
dude that's
game
changing and and dude all right kwixel
is also
free
with unreal engine that is that's just
bonkers that i think that is the
unreal's biggest strength right now
because i've had a lot of people ask me
like well hey like why oops sorry um if
why would i use ue unreal when i could
just use blender and blender might
render faster better and have all the
the better less headaches basically
we're rendering in blender um i would
say i agree
but unreal does have its fair share of
advantages that you know no other dcc
has and that's the entire crystal mega
scan for free
not just
insane
what does dcc stand for by the way uh so
digital content creator or i think it is
got so digital content creation or yeah
well usually when we refer to a dcc i'm
referring to like maya 3ds max blender
unreal
anything that creates content
got you okay and
so um
why would i love my trainers but
uh
yeah so people ask me you know wondering
why would you use on renal well
crystal megascans is one of the main
things second one is i love the content
browser like i don't know any other
application that has something quite
like this like the fact that you can
search through your content so fast so
quickly
um migrating from one project to another
so quickly you can just have a whole
library of assets just with you know
great thumbnails and everything easily
accessible
it is a solid content browser yeah it's
really good and i don't know like
obviously i've not used
all the other
applications out there it's like you're
from you're a c4d guy right i am
so does c4d have something like that
they have the
uh
shoot what's it called uh i forget the
name of it but it's kind of like this
it's kind of like that it's it
is it straight up called the content
browser um oh it might be okay i'm
blanking on that but that's what beeple
uses he uses that all the time so he
basically like stores all of his assets
in a easy to view setup kind of like
this where like you have the thumbnails
and you just drag and drop them into
your scene but it's not as like
set up i mean it's just a window it's
just a window that you dock somewhere um
but i i love ue5 they they they took the
uh
one of my favorite things about after
effects is the uh the andrew kramer's
like it's called like vc console or
something like that and it if you hit
control space or shift space you can set
it up however you want it will pull up a
search bar for all the effects um that
you want to look at oh gotcha i didn't
know that oh my god i the first thing
i'll install uh with after effects is
that gotcha it's the best thing ever
and it saves you so much time and ue5 is
doing that they do the same even the
same shortcut control spacebar to pull
up the content browser it's like
and it gives it it's great because it
gives you more room to see what you're
creating
it's funny because i actually disabled
that feature in ue5 when i use it
because um i
like no secret i have a pretty crappy
gpu i'm using a 2060 super and it's fine
it's a good little card it's got ray
tracing and everything it's great uh but
it's still not a beefy graphics card and
[Music]
yeah so
excuse me
so uh when um i need to drink a water
water go for it go for it
okay so when i'm um
when i'm working like i actually prefer
to have a slightly smaller viewport
because my frame rate's higher
got you i see
so when i have go full screen like my
frame rate just tanks it goes to
something like you know 5 fps like okay
i can't work uh but when i have a
smaller viewport like my frame rate goes
way up because it's rendering you know
it's like 480p or something so
it's um
it's much better that way for me that's
a great tip man i love it heck yeah so
if if i were to like make my screen like
this you can kind of see
my frame rate like you know 40 50 fps
and then when i you do this
now it's
okay it got higher how did that happen
well that wasn't supposed to happen
but um
yeah normally obviously it kind of goes
without saying the the smaller your
viewport the better your performance is
going to be
that makes a lot of sense somehow it
would probably happen because i'm
streaming and my gpu is being all weird
um so maybe that's why but yeah
uh we got some more super chats to shout
out so let's start with jeff says what's
up clint i see they got that new rococo
suit coming out 2022. i want to mess
with that and unreal and make some
bad ass music videos um yeah absolutely
i want to mess with it too
um i
haven't shared this yet
but um i am going to be a judge on their
contest that they're running right now
um i'm gonna you know i'll instagram and
tweet it uh i've been so busy but
yeah there it's it's you know for the
release of their new suit um they're
running a cool contest you don't have to
have a suit or own the program to
enter but i think they're giving away
suits and gloves and everything as grand
prizes so
definitely check that out over at rococo
and uh
jeff
thank you thank you sarah thank you for
the super chat very kind of you vj
um thanks again
very very generous of you uh he says
thanks william and clint for clarifying
i'm using blender with octane and love
the result so wondering if it's good to
use octane with unreal as
well i know they i've heard some people
use that
i have not used it myself yeah yeah yeah
i have not used it myself either
but i've
you know they're working on it they're
con they're crunching on it
um yeah so so i've heard um
i'm not so
i'm not actually not even familiar with
the cloud it's just essentially
using octane to render what you have in
your unreal scene and then just going
from there
dude i don't even know
it's a weird thing where like
i'm so weird sometimes with programs
i
when i first started learning cinema 4d
um i was using the standard renderer the
physical renderer which is like why
would you ever
use that renderer why would you just not
use octane because ren was like dude you
gotta use octane i'm like nah i gotta
learn the standard renderer first and
i should have just skipped straight to
octane um
now with unreal i'm in unreal i'm like
doing the real time and my the whole
draw of unreal was real time i'm like
why would i want to render anything i
want to do it real time so
you know that's what i'm rolling with
right now
maybe in the future i will experiment
with a renderer like octane in unreal
but for now i'm like
i'm jamming on what they got you know
yeah i think it kind of depends where
you might want to have like all the
benefits that unreal offers like you
know mega scans and the content browser
and like just the general ease of use of
unreal i say ease of use and that's i
realize that's not applicable to
everyone i say either of you because i'm
just familiar with it i'm very
comfortable and unreal so i love working
in ue4
um so people might prefer that that ease
of working getting that real time you
know previz stuff
and then you know you're opting for
final pickle renders
yeah yeah i think like having all of the
options available to you and knowing
what those options are having familiar
with the options and how to tweak those
options is
certainly a smart thing to do um you
know
there's no reason why you'd be like
you know i have my screwdriver i have my
drill bits and i got
uh a hammer why would i want to use that
i'm throwing that away you know like
you're probably gonna want to use a
hammer at some point um
so that's good
good to know
uh in general i'd say
um yeah
and d mccoy i see ya thank you for the
super chat you say after school i moved
to la2 and then from there to montreal
best choice i've made
this
helps me get my foot in the door nice to
see you guys come together great job
sweet thank you dee mccoy for the super
chat very kind of you um montreal i've
been there once but you said william
that's where you spent most of your
childhood yes that's right well not my
child my adult life yeah yeah
yeah my child's a great place
do you ski
snowboard i do
what what's your preference
i've i've been snowboarding most of my
life so i'm definitely more of a
snowboarder but since moving to norway
like cross country skiing is a big thing
here so i've been doing a lot of that
here as well sweet
yeah it's like it's one of those things
where like people do it because it's
actually trendy here like when you think
of cross-country skiing in north america
it's like
boring
and
but like here it's just like no it's
like the national sport like what it's
what people do
um
like people who do who are you know
cross-country heroes like they are
legends here wow
very different uh very different culture
for that
that's awesome
i have been snowboarding a handful of
times skiing a handful of times um we're
actually going to vancouver a little
later this year tonight
to go to whistler are you gonna go to
wisdom yeah nice that's uh that is such
an amazing place i'd love it there i'm
so excited i'm very excited
how long you going for
oh we're gonna be there for like five
days
that's a good amount of time it's decent
yeah yeah it'll be solid
i mean you're from like warper climates
right so i'm guessing snow is not
something you've uh
kind of dealt with that much
i never had snow as a kid i always
wanted it um and i've only experienced
it a number of times
and i love it every time i see it every
time i go it's like
it's the best
yeah i love my snow it's all snowy here
now so uh
i'm a happy kid
that's awesome
how'd your environment look in there
my scene
yep
yeah
it's okay
um
trying to figure out like
what this is
i need to throw some pipes in here i'll
throw some pipes in yeah
there we go
so we probably have another like
solid hour to cool that's great that's
great things are slowly starting to
get together there and getting some tech
stuff set up there and
yeah
and then we'll review the art from the
weekly challenge
sure
is that more everything that you do
yourself or that we do that together or
oh yeah we'll do it together
okay cool yeah
it won't take more than
15 minutes
after that hour of uh
of creating the art here
yeah it works for me
all right i gotta add some freaking
pipes
man the built-in mega scans like
it's it's amazing right it's just it's
so good
yeah dude that's next level
yeah that's definitely one of my
favorite features of um
of duty five in general it's just it's
just so good i i just
i love it
makes it easy
you know i was just telling you earlier
that i rarely have issues with unreal
now well that was a lie
all right i'll switch over to you what's
going on
oh yeah nicole no pressure right
crap yeah i'm trying to get the uh
runtime virtual texturing stuff set up
like i was texting you earlier so
normally right here is where you should
get a nice a nice blend in with the
ground where i can control that fall off
and stuff uh kind of what you're seeing
here so i can cut it will blend into
the
concrete here so it can be like dust or
something or have dirt blending in
and so it really helps with that you
know this nasty line there uh but i
can't quite figure out why it's not
working right now so that's fun
troubleshooting man troubleshooting that
was another question we had was
let's see who is it who is it we did
have that question
yeah let's see i want to give these
names right
[Music]
uh jonathan
peters 23 on instagram how do you get
solutions to very specific issues
a lot of googling a whole lot of
googling uh youtube is another great one
uh otherwise i use like some of the
unreal forums um which is kind of
it's a great place to look because
chances are if you have a question
someone else has asked that same
question before yeah so
uh the unreal forums are a fantastic
place for that um it's you know either
you can sign in and ask a question
yourself but
nine times out of ten that question has
been asked so it's a matter of finding
that obscure
forum thread somewhere from like 2013
where someone asked like your specific
question and cryptic user
69420 asked the exact same question that
you had and you need to like find out
and then of course like like they just
write like oh thanks guys i found a
solution without posting the solution
because he's a jerk yeah
and you're like no what did you do how
did you find it so there's definitely a
lot of googling and of course it's also
just a trial and error
um
which is yeah it's uh
that's the main way to solve things but
just just brute force it sometimes you
don't have much of a choice so
yeah
yeah googling for sure knowing how to
google is uh
is a huge one
it sure is
where is that
i don't even know do i even have any
any comments on
how to google properly uh
goodness
that's a video in itself
that is a good that's a good that's a
really good question actually
because it's like i know what i would
google
but i'd see someone else google
something i'd be like that's not what
you should be googling
right it's like an intuition
yeah i think so i think it's a trial and
error as well i think that's something
you kind of learn with time
um but i should that's definitely food
for thought um
given more time to think about that
question i could come up with a more
elaborate
and better answer
than uh just you know
intuition bro yeah
exactly
um
but
yeah i think it's a mad i think for me
solving issues is less about actually
fixing the problem at hand and more
going up going about it without the
process of elimination so you try to
factor it you would you uh
you assess the situation and you try to
factor out as many things as you can
like okay
open up the scene in a different version
of unreal is my problem still there no
great i know it's not a you know it's
not like a program a pr
uh what's the word it's not a project
setting so you know you can factor that
out and you can try something else okay
does this happen in another scene in
another environment you try to replicate
this the problem and that's where you
start narrowing down
the source of your problem and that's i
think that's kind of where you you
eventually figure stuff out
yeah 100 it's just like fixing your
computer uh my computer is not turning
on okay well unplug everything besides
the power cable and your keyboard
yep okay still not turning on that'll
fix it sometimes
yeah yeah that'll fix it sometimes and
then like you'll get the beeps like what
do these beeps mean okay we'll like
uh consult your motherboard manual and
see what the four beeps mean okay
i gotta plug in a monitor ah i see
they whittle it down as many as little
factors as possible exactly you just
process the elimination
eventually you'll get it fixed
but sometimes it can be just like oh i
have like an sd card plugged in and for
some reason my dumb computer tried to
boot off my sd card i can't tell you how
many times but that has happened like uh
yes i have had a card reader literally
like it crashed windows every time every
single time and i uh took me forever to
realize it was a bad card reader
yeah you wouldn't think that like
computers are stupid
yeah
they have to hear the actual worst like
i've been booting this computer every
day for like two years
and for some reason now decide like oh
you mean you want to boot off this sd
card right sure god got you bro
and uh it's like why would you do that
you
jerk
all right
and also a good solution to like fixing
your problem is sometimes if you get
locked onto a problem just move on to
something else like unless it's like
actual like a show stopper um move on to
something else especially you know when
time is tight
uh don't waste your time just
noodling around with something that
ultimately is not that important right
so just focus on on what does matter on
the important stuff and then once you
have time once you've gotten like the
big chunks out of the way then you can
go back
and uh and fix those issues but
it's so dangerous sometimes you're in a
production you know you want to fix it
and just the way my brain works like it
captured all of my brain's cpu resources
and just
i can't think of anything else until i
fix that problem but that's just not the
right way to go about things
yeah i waste so much time
on stupid stuff on like ocd stuff and
i try to catch myself every time i do it
and it's so hard because i love
it's really procrastination that's what
it is i'm like just wasting time like
reordering or renaming things that
really don't need to be renamed like
just it really doesn't matter
yeah but don't get me wrong keeping a
clean scene is really important um i get
really irrationally angry with people
who have like the messiest outliners and
scenes in general
um
really makes me angry when people just
have it's a mess like you open up their
scene and they're you know they're sick
one day you have to take over their
scene and it's just like oh man you
monster yeah why would you why would you
why
what are you doing
it's funny you know but like
so working at corridor right um is
working with the team and yeah sometimes
you're opening
well a lot of a lot of times you're
actually most of the time you're
collaborating with people
um creating things together opening
scenes and all that stuff that someone
else has used and like
i
i think that me sam and ren was like the
perfect balance of
of vfx artists because like i am so ocd
about organization and cleanliness and
like everything's gonna be named
properly and then sam
sam is just like
i'm gonna just get this done as fast as
possible and it's gonna look great and
i'm like but these aren't organized
and i'm like sam you gotta organize it a
little bit and then it seems like no but
we need to work we need to get the
deadline we need to work faster i'm like
oh you're right you're right so like we
would balance each other out really
nicely and then it's just like going
crazy with ideas and like
i think it's that's uh yeah
you need a balance
for sure for sure
yeah i definitely work with people who
are just you know really anal about
the things that are not that important
like bro we've got like a delivery in
you know tomorrow like
get the shots out we'll clean up and i
know it's not ideal but life is not a
deal so
yeah for sure but the thing is like it's
always if i know someone else is gonna
pick up my scene i clean up my act
because i it's almost it's embarrassing
when i'm like oh no he's going to pick
up my shot oh it's a mess
oh no this is so embarrassing
it's like someone walks into your room
and it's just your underwear everywhere
it's like
uh yeah pretty much that's that's
exactly how i feel
so uh yeah it's good to stay organized
and um
especially when you're handing stuff up
because
it just it saves them time too because
they don't have to figure out what the
heck you were doing you know
it's like trying to pick up someone's
render or their materials or shaders or
whatever and it's just what is going on
like a really complex shader network a
complex tree of noodles and you know
nothing
and what what happened what happened
here
brutal
a corridor were you mostly doing like
youtube stuff or did you guys have a
client work as well or zero clients
it was made up
youtube yeah 100
um
you know because they had they could
they could just do what they wanted and
um right
why would you take clients unless
it works
for a video you know so like there'd be
instances where like
nico
you you would have like a youtuber i
forget which youtuber it was ask hey can
you deep fake this thing because we're
trying to do deep fake like tupac
for a snoop dogg music video could you
help us and nico would be like uh
yeah
that sounds awesome um right
and you want me on set and i get to meet
snoop dogg okay can we make a video
about it
yeah okay yeah that works out you know
so stuff like that you know right
yeah no that's awesome that's not that's
the dream because client work is
it's fine they you know it pays the
bills so uh but not all clients are fun
to work with
true
true yeah true stick with the good ones
keep the connection with the good ones
um yeah it's just sometimes like the
boring jobs are the one that you know
they pay the most right so uh yeah yeah
sometimes you just gotta you just gotta
do it suck it up and just go for it
for sure it's your livelihood at that
point it's like
yep you gotta gotta make ends meet
but man sometimes some clients are just
not not cool like some sometimes they're
actually on an ego trip
where you know they will they will
just pixel peep every single thing
you've got it's just it's absurd
um it's just no fun for everyone i think
they get some kind of sense of
validation by just needlessly critiquing
your work i mean they're paying so of
course they're the boss uh but sometimes
it's just like oh this one railing in
the back is uh
the chrome is too shiny but like it's
motion blur did the field like you can't
even tell it's chrome but you know they
still want it to
change
man that's what i loved about working
with uh the guys at corridor is they're
like it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter does it look good when
you play when you hit play and you watch
it one time
that's the dream yeah man it's
but then also like you know when we do
vfx arts react and and i was sitting
down with the the vfx uh supervisor from
chongqi and he was just telling me dude
every
single thing i mean you you were a vfx
artist on a marvel movie right
yep
so yeah i'm sure you know it's like
it's absurd the level of
like your work your renders are going to
go through
so many people it goes through your
supervisor it goes to his supervisor go
to the head of cg then it goes to the
client and it goes you know then the
client can be any number of people it
can be like the actual producer then it
can be the director it can be
there's so many people looking at your
work just tearing it apart and just
viewing it under the most absurd of
situations uh
and it's just like man like you're you
know they're they're increasing the
contrast like crazy to see like how the
shadows are if there's too much noise in
the shadows and stuff like but like the
client the viewer is never gonna see
this
um but you know like i said they're
they're they're paying so they're the
boss
um
yeah
when they are on an ego trip is that
when like i've actually had clients
where
um
they
they would tell me like okay this needs
to be fixed this needs to be fixed which
is you know fair enough
um
but sometimes like if i knew it was just
like an absurd request so i would send
them the next day
i have sent the exact same render
it just versioned the name so version
five instead of version four
and they're like oh this is perfect
thank you
and you know you know they were on an
ego trip dude um
i have a very similar story i forget who
told this to me but
it was someone in color correction and
they were saying how
they would just have these nightmare
clients
tweaking
every single frame every shadow
highlight in mid-tone
and
what they did was they would have a
client knob
like basically here let me demonstrate
so basically like
you got me on this thing by the way
uh this like
oh yeah yeah blackmagic quick edit thing
so they'd have the client
have one of these uh they'd be on the
knob right here and like yeah just very
slowly very slowly turn the knob until
it looks good to you and they're like
that actually looks great yeah that
looks great but the knob wasn't plugged
in it didn't do anything
it was just like
a freaking kid's toy to play with so
that they thought they were doing
something yeah i'm like oh man that
could get you in trouble but that is
hilarious
i mean it was a calculated risk yeah
oh that's gold i love it
yeah so good it's like those are the
stories you just love to hear it's like
yes we won another
yeah i mean but then i like i complain
but you know doing work for myself like
out of the freelancer it's just it's
still so much better like
100 yeah than doing it like if you have
to like rip your hair out for for
someone else for a studio it's like ah
man
but again
yeah but then again studio life has been
some of the best times of my life as
well so you know i i'm
complaining about studio work but like
it's it's also been amazing so i really
um
yeah
i'm sure you love that i mean you go
about all the time you love your time at
corridor right so
it really was a dream job it really was
um there's no getting around that and uh
i i yeah you know i just felt that like
the only way to do exactly what i wanted
to do was to just do it myself um
and like there are things that i won't
really want to do like make a feature
film that is it just wasn't possible
there because it wasn't in line with
like what they were doing um which is
sure totally fine people think like oh
but what they won't let you do what blah
blah it's like it's a business come on
at the end of the day like they're
running their business the way they feel
is best to run their business and i'm
not saying they're running the business
poorly it's actually
incredible how they're doing it um and
i've taken a lot of pointers from sam
nico and jake and everybody from ren too
on how to run my channel so and i was
literally there yesterday playing smash
bros with them for a node and like
um
but yeah at the end of the day it's just
like
the venn diagram the venn diagram was
pretty massive like the overlap was
pretty massive but there was still some
stuff on the outside on my side that i
that was very important to me that that
just outweighed the
you know so it's all chill though man
like we all love each other so much
that's good
oh yeah yeah no it's i mean it's a whole
learning experience like like i said
like working at um working in vfx was
for five years was like the
most amazing learning experience because
i really enjoyed like we had like
dailies meetings every day right that's
just what you do and we'd like analyze
our shop we go over what we did the day
before and like i was really lucky to
have an amazing vfx supervisor who was
just probably one of the smartest people
i know and who just knew his stuff when
it comes to vfx he knew you know he was
a render he was literally a render
engineer he was right like he worked at
weta
and he was he wrote his own render
engine
goodness
not many people can do that and uh so
you know he was he was doing some of
that
and he was just fascinating to listen to
it like he would analyze your shots and
just
kind of pick it apart but in the most
constructive way in the most helpful way
ever and that is what really helps you
grow
as an artist especially when it's really
constructive stuff it's not just
nitpicking for the sake of nitpicking um
that's when you get really really really
helpful you're like okay like this
doesn't look good because of xyz and
when it's constructive and he tells it
in a non-condescending manner um that's
when you just you just thrive like you
want to impress it right you want to to
to show like hey i listen to your advice
and hear what it turned out
and uh it was really great i loved my
time there that's awesome
having someone who can be a
a mentor and a guide
is
such a blessing um not everyone is
equipped to do it
definitely not and not everyone's
equipped to handle it either like some
people just do not accept criticism like
they just cannot accept it at all they
did to take it to they take it
personally often it's a thing where they
just they can't
handle the criticism um and that is
definitely something that a lot of
people need to accept if you're going to
work in this industry
accept criticism and that's how you're
going to learn and grow it's not
personal
use it as a way to get better
yes it goes both ways though because you
have to give it in a kind way you have
to give it in a very like loving
constructive way and not
look down on the person or judge the
person for doing
it that way like they're learning
they're new they're brand new like yep
what do you expect
um
so
it's definitely on both sides to like
be responsible and like be grown-ups
about it and like
take the most from it so
yep
yeah i think that's definitely what
helped me the most
when i was starting off like
back in 2008 like four i mean just see
3d forums were like a really big thing
like were you uh did you know about poly
count
no
no so poly count was a game art forum uh
that really would like focus on game art
and
the polygon forums were they used to be
a very small
tight-knit group of people and these
were like industry professional people
working at ubisoft people working at
relic games in vancouver uh like people
really really skilled people and
if you posted your work there
they would demolish you but in a very
constructive way
and it was it was rough like they would
really be pretty brutal in their
feedback but
if you if they noticed that you know you
you
took their notes into consideration you
applied their criticism to your work and
you repost it again
they would be like man awesome then they
would just like promote your work even
more and more it was an amazing learning
experience and i think i'm where i am
today because of the poly account forms
it's hard to find that nowadays that
just doesn't exist
um anymore
i don't think i mean it now i think it's
more on discord is more of the thing now
discord and
i guess there's still some forums around
but not much discord is pretty great
like i mean that's what i try and do
with my servers i try and have it be
like an open place where people can
um ask questions like sure i mean the
whole thing is learning and growing
together that's like the phrase the
catchphrase or the motto is we're all
we're all learning and growing together
so
drop the ego and let's be constructive
and have fun um i like that
yeah so and and i i know ash is actually
um ashlar he
feels very similar about it like it's
always learning always growing i think
that's his thing too um and i i couldn't
agree more like we
we
don't know the answers
none of us know all the answers um
and as soon as you realize that like oh
or if you accept
well that's the wrong word if you think
you know all the answers then you're
done like you've you've lost
yep oh yeah i totally agree yeah
yeah no the world is too small i mean
it's just i'm still learning constantly
like i've been using unreals in 2008 and
i'm still learning new things every day
every time i use unreal like just my
last video like just the silliest thing
about saving you know tons of gigabytes
at this space i had no idea no clue
whatsoever and uh you know like i said
still learning and there's no
there's not enough time to learn all the
things even though i would love to spend
i'd love to take like a week or a month
off just to learn houdini or blender or
something but that's not going to happen
uh yeah
do you use a 3d you said you're in maya
i'm in maya yeah okay but i mean i've
been doing mostly unreal now like i
haven't touched maya i don't even have a
maya license because i just don't use it
um nowadays i just use unreal for 90 of
my work so
sweet it's awesome
yeah you're like you're definitely in
c4d for the most part right
recently it's just it's been unreal like
i i okay
i found a really cool like i
probably shouldn't say this
but i just
got this new computer uh puget
workstation and
i hadn't installed c4d yet
i just
it's just unreal right now
i i need to i like i literally had a
mild panic attack when i realized i
didn't have c4d on my computer because
i'm like crap i got i might need to
model something or like
import some custom thing but i mean no
no i'll keep it simple i'm just going to
do with quixil stuff today so yep oh i
mean you can get do so that's the beauty
of the cuisine um mega skins you can get
you can do so much
yeah
it's
the best it gets the job done it's not
perfect great
what that sorry it's like legos man it's
the best i love it i know
i know and they it's just growing every
day it's getting better and better and
you know eventually i'm probably gonna
start scanning my own stuff you know
i've got reality capture now and uh so i
got a video with with them coming up
soon no way are you serious yeah yeah me
too
oh yeah oh no no way that's awesome yeah
dude that's awesome they got perfected
by epic right so uh yeah
so yeah though they're just cranking out
the good stuff it's uh really looking
forward to that oh dude we gotta we
gotta chat behind the scenes then to
figure out like if we can so we don't
double dip so we're like we're giving
the audience two different legs of like
of the thing so and we can even point to
each other's videos or something too
that should be sweet
yeah definitely they would i don't think
they will object to that like oh you had
more
more eyes on our content sure
absolutely everyone's in the family it's
awesome
what would you say like your biggest
strength is it modeling is that like i
know you said roto so you've been a bit
of a copper yourself
um
yes i compositing is probably the thing
i've done most um but i don't enjoy it
most i
yeah that's a good question what are my
strengths wow
um
yeah the job interview by the way just
so you know
what's your biggest stress and
weaknesses
good question
i was i'm switching your screen for this
well i think about it um that's fair
enough
my strengths would probably be my drive
i i constantly
want to push myself to make better stuff
i
love
creating photo real environments
and like atmospheric
moody scenes that i'd say that's a
strength of mine
um
i'm pretty
fast at editing
uh
i
generally know how to composite pretty
well because it's the thing i've done
most
gotcha and i love
making shaders i really do love making
shaders it's like so so zen i love that
awesome yeah
um weaknesses animation
modeling
um
simulation stuff
any character stuff
uh
um
i'm just trying to think of all the
things there are like everything like
everything that i didn't mention i'm i'm
bad at
um
[Music]
and he
any other weaknesses i don't know what
do you think what do you think are your
strengths and weaknesses
um i mean like i said i've always been a
bit of a generalist right so i think
that's been
my biggest strength is just the ability
to just kind of pick up anything and
i'll i'll learn it reasonably quickly
i'm never going to be like a legend of
animation but i can animate um i've done
like i've done some animation in black
panther and uh
you know that i knew after a while and
that was kind of the strength that i had
at my previous job is that um it was a
smaller studio it was a it was one of
the best vfx studios in norway but it's
still a pretty small shop
um so due to the small nature of things
sometimes you know if someone would be
sick or you had like a dad who had to go
pick up his kid at kindergarten and like
hey well you need to kind of fill in
this role for the next week like sure
whatever and so you know i just either
did threw me into comping for a month
and then they like okay we need an
animator to animate this shot or
sometimes just tell me hey you need to
do this entire shot yourself so i do the
match move i do the animation get the
cameras all set up and they would do the
modeling the
look dev the all the shaders i would do
all the lighting and then the rendering
and then i don't think i never took it
all the way through the comp but
i'm almost there
so it was kind of a bit of a one-man
army there and i loved it i think it was
a lot of fun and that was a really good
learning experience because it's not
it's one thing to tell to force yourself
to do it at home it's another when you
don't have a choice like hey you need to
finish these shots by next week
and then you're like well
i'll figure it out then yeah and uh and
that's the best way to learn you learn
under that pressure and that's something
that's really hard to do
on your own
um and that's the kind of kind of go
segway that's what we were talking about
earlier like people who don't have that
same drive who don't that discipline to
force themselves to to learn and
struggle
um
working in a studio or school in general
will really help you with that
yeah or having a youtube channel
uh yeah oh it keeps you on your toes
certainly because you can't put out info
that's like not
correct you have to i mean i i've said
things that are wrong uh
sure in the past on my youtube stuff on
the educational stuff like that are just
straight up i said it wrong i thought it
was right it was wrong um
i think it's gonna happen but like
uh it definitely keeps you on your toes
and it makes you really push yourself to
know what you're talking about to the
best of your ability because you don't
want to be a fraud you don't be a hack
you don't no sure
certainly certainly and even like
doing tutorials that like other people
have done too feels weird at times too
um
yeah
you know like
i did feel a little bit of me felt weird
that like
i learned so much stuff from you
recently and i
put a lot of those things that i learned
in my unreal breakdown video for that
hey music video that's fine
because you're putting your own spin on
it that's fine yeah i think as long as
you put your own spin on it and like i
look like to me it just it gives me um
peace of mind to shout out that person
um sure
very much like you did on your last
video with that guy on twitter you shout
it out like gotta gotta you know point
the audience to where it came from and
then oh a hundred percent yeah yeah
there's no shame in giving credit where
credit is due like it doesn't devalue
myself it doesn't make me get have less
credit like for making the video um i
think it just it just makes them
appreciate like okay hey like you know
they they thought about me and you know
did they you know send some clicks my
way and that's fine as long as you push
your own spin on it you give credit
where credit is due it's fine to cover
content that's been covered before
because everything's already been done
yeah
so it's impossible to be kind of
original in day and age now
yeah i mean you can
come off as original
um but it may not be truely original um
yeah there's a there's a great book
called hit makers and it talks about
okay how
things get popular
and
one of the brief like this is like my
main takeaway from the book was that
there's a there's basically what he
calls is the 80 20 rule where when
you're creating something
whether it be
um new clothing a new movie uh
a bubblegum wrapper a new car
whatever
uh when you're designing something
eighty percent of that design is
uh recognizable you you know you know it
you've seen it before but the other
twenty percent is fresh and totally
different it throws it's just a it's a
different combo you know it's a
different one too so that twenty percent
is like i've never seen
i don't know uh
space mixed with
now steampunk or whatever you know
but that's probably like
there's a bunch of movies like that
actually
yeah but you you know you get what i'm
saying it's the 80 20. yeah absolutely
no you you kind of put your own spit on
things and yeah that's fine
i think that's about as good as the
issue i have is when people like they'll
they'll just take your you know i had a
guy and i'm not going to point a finger
but i had a guy who i had made a
tutorial and like literally the day
after made the exact same tutorial with
no credit whatsoever and i'm just like
bro
come on like and of course like at the
time i was a much smaller channel and he
was a much bigger channel than i was so
i'm like really are you just gonna
blatantly copy verbatim what i did and
it's not like it's not like it was a new
tool that he had you know he was
covering it's not like we were both
covering the same plugin this was like
an actual workflow thing like hey this
is my workflow for achieving xyz
oh and you think there's no way that he
could have like
it is impossible for him to have covered
to do the exact same thing i'm like dude
really are you really going to do that
dang
so that that's where i have an issue but
like people covering the same you know
the same topics and you know saying but
that's fine that that's totally okay
there's nothing wrong with that
yeah yeah agreed
that's crazy that's have you ever had
issues with like you know just like
haters in general i mean we all have
them right but what's like for for
anyone
and online because it's a scary place
like the internet is vicious sometimes
and
what is your advice for for new artists
who are you know you know might be
scared or
you know just nervous about posting
their art on our station social media
and getting their work out there
that's a good
question it's a really good question i i
would say get involved in a group of
people that's doing it it's always
easier to do it with a group of people
so
you know like
you know the discord server or
um
you know any sort of community of people
that's doing it like let's follow
different instagram accounts that you
enjoy or follow people on twitter that
do maybe do challenges together or
something like that yeah um
that helps
that certainly helps and you're part of
something
that isn't just you you're adding to
something that's greater
um
so i think that's a great way to
actually start posting your stuff online
is post it with people um
and then you're gonna get better you're
gonna
you know maybe on your fifth
piece of art that you put out your fifth
render you're like this one is the best
one i've done
hands down
i'm excited to share this and
then you share it because you're excited
but
the ones that you're scared about
like we we we have to we don't actually
no we don't have to post we have to post
anything actually you can just create
art
um by yourself
for yourself only i know ash does that
he makes art for just him and for no one
else and i'm like dude
that is crazy like i good for him i mean
huh
i haven't i would struggle with that
like i feel like i i'm just like anxious
like oh i really want to get this out to
the world i i mean humblebrag almost
like i want to get this out right um i
think that's what a lot of arts want to
do it's good for him for just doing it
for himself
i know right uh dude your scene looks
great by the way i'm going to full
screen oh
thanks
screen didn't work your scene can you uh
yeah sure
so it's got a render real quick but uh
yeah there we go so
tacoma what is that
uh this is the ford raptor
it's actually uh ashlorp's car
that's right
that's funny
uh thanks the d-noises are a bit
aggressive here um i need to give more
samples but you know my jeep my poor
little gpu is uh kind of suffering right
now
that's awesome oh yeah i'm using the
path tracer right now just because like
i said pass tracer is just
really nice for j it's just so fast
because it's basically a octane for
unreal right it's basically um
what are the blender cycles i think it
is um it's unreal so there's no there's
no baking involved there's no you don't
need to rely on you know just
anything else it just it just works
right so it's kind of like the idiot
proof way of doing things
and uh so it's kind of it's not real
time anymore obviously so you kind of
lose that advantage but sometimes you
know it's nice to just get like a ground
truth type of thing
yeah
yeah absolutely
it does have its own set of issues like
the volumetrics don't work decals don't
work which is a real bummer because
decals are just amazing and unreal but
oh wait do you don't work with the path
tracer with that's correct oh snap man
so steve begin uh who is actually
watching the stream right now shout outs
to steve sensei steve um he he's the guy
who
taught me
most of what i know in unreal um okay he
took the time out of his day
to to help me um
so huge shout outs to steve um and he
blew my mind with the decals i was like
what oh so good
dude it like changes you don't have
those in c4d i thought oh maybe that's a
blender thing
no there's no volumetric decal anything
like that and it's
dude it's so good
yeah i know it's just a free way of
adding detail anywhere and everywhere so
easily um big fan definitely a big fan
hey question for you
yeah is there an easy way to duplicate
this ladder 100 times
like this just down down down down down
down
no i don't think so uh you're gonna what
i do is i just kind of
duplicate one select two and then
duplicate those two and then just
exponentially go and go uh i wish like
maya has a tool for each i think it's
shifty or something and just like
you just spam that shortcut and just
duplicates in a series
yeah
but no i don't think so i mean you can
create a blue uh
uh blueprint for it
um and that's essentially going to
duplicate things along a spline but you
you kind of set it up and such which is
kind of a bit of a pain
to answer your question like quick
quickly and dirty i don't think there's
a way although that's not
yeah no not really
i know you can make a shortcut for like
you know you can um
there's a shortcut for like place
ass actor here or something so you
select something in your content browser
and you can do the shortcut you can spam
it and it'll place an actor wherever
your mouse cursor is
okay which can be super super useful um
but yeah i think you have to set the
keyboard shortcut for that
okay got you
let's see now i'm i i'm super
disappointed i can't get my runtime
virtual texturing to work on my ground
which is really annoying but
uh that's one of those things sometimes
it is what it is
yep
i like your thing too it's coming along
quite nice thank you yeah i'm just like
in the
detail part at this point i'm using a
a table
upside down table as a walkway
it's so far away
if it works
it's just a silhouette right so and
that's that's actually a great tip for
a lot of people is sometimes you don't
need to do
everything perfectly
like you wouldn't believe it sometimes
it's a very creative reason why i use
depth of field so much is because it's
just blurred out and so you just need
some kind of silhouette
yep
silhouettes man that's it's all about i
love me some silhouettes i love that
style so much um yeah
ah man we were talking about this dune
freaking dune oh yes
so good like the freaking cinematography
in that movie uh it's a beauty i mean
you know that you know what their
process was right so they shot that
digitally
and then they scanned or sorry i think
they reprojected the digital onto
film negatives yeah to get the film to
get the film grain and then they scan
that back again
afterwards
dude that's which
it's like that that's some serious
dedication
that's legit man i i love it like
that's the most expensive way to add
film could you imagine doing your
youtube tutorials adding film grain to
your youtube tutorials like that yeah no
i'm good
sending it in like that
uh i mean i shouldn't need davinci
resolve for that man
yeah seriously seriously
like the the film stocks you can get now
or they look just as good like i i would
be very curious to see
like a side-by-side comparison
electricity the actual raw digital file
scan and then compared to the raw
digital file with some just a noise
applied in post instead um i'm sure like
knowing the director i'm sure there was
a very good reason he decided to do that
oh for sure yeah i mean it's like
he he's he's a film buff you know you
gotta
you gotta do it right um
and
most of me feels
like
yeah i agree with them you got to do it
right um yep but then there's a small
part of me that's like
i'm assuming what other people feel like
yeah yeah which is like that's stupid
um but i mean
yeah i mean when you have the budget why
not
yeah like you wanna i'm a perfectionist
man so it's like you gotta do it legit
if you're spending all this money on
this movie give it the right treatment
you know like set it up properly
yeah i like i said i would love just
like just the the the photography nerd
in me would just love to see like a
side-by-side comparison to like hey like
was this
what was the actual gain they got here
yeah that's a great question
but we'll never know we can only
anticipate urge to take wild guesses i
guess
did you read the book
i did not i i actually had never heard
of dune until like you know it was
announced that they were making a movie
on it okay
did you
i i bought it after i watched the movie
okay you started reading it or uh yeah
um
it's confusing how is it like is it
writing any good like i
um
i
loved the movie
so i
i guess i'm biased so i went into it
with
like a positive mindset
right um
and then
from there it's pretty confusing to be
honest
there's so many words and terminology
and things that like
i'm like okay i just don't really need
to know what that means
i don't think sure
and i'm gonna try not to to let that
like
taint
my uh
feeling of it
yeah but i just want to be in that world
again so i'm loving it like i'm loving
it for that reason you know
yeah i know that that makes sense is it
one of those things is it possible
you're just too early in the book to get
a feel for it because for example like
game of thrones
when you first start reading game of
thrones it's just like what and what is
going on there's like so many names it
is super complicated but once you get
you know the
the hang of it it is so good it is like
such a good book
yeah it's definitely that vibe right now
it's 100 of that vibe and i'm like
i just need to invest a little bit of
time in it and it's going to be safe yep
hopefully
yeah now that makes sense i thought you
just need to get into the environment
and into the world right like the the
world building aspect of that movie was
just fantastic
um like like we were talking about
earlier it's a bit of a slow film but i
i kind of dig it i love that they just
took the time to really just set the
pace at the tone
um you really get a feel of like where
they're living um
yeah it was masterpiece
yeah i'm really glad they're making a
second one or that they really i guess
it was popular enough to justify a
second one i suppose because they were
definitely that that period where they
weren't sure if it was going to be green
lit or not
ah the second one
yeah okay that was not a sure thing
i didn't know that um
i'm excited they're yeah i'm excited
they're doing a second one because i
just want to be in that world it's
really good
are there any movies that like inspired
you to do what you do now
oh my god
yeah
um
[Music]
i mean i my
my
aspiration is to direct movies
um right not not cg movies but live
action movies and okay yeah
i think the one of the earliest movies
that
had an impact on me i got
it's weird because i actually didn't
grow up part of me doesn't remember i'm
gonna be honest part of me doesn't
remember i don't know um but the other
part of me grew up with jackie chan and
bruce lee um okay those guys are my
favorite and they're so freaking cool i
loved it so much
and i was in martial arts as a kid
it was the jam and
that
like those guys are what got me into
movies and then from there
you know why
my dad showed me
the matrix
and i was like this is the best movie
ever um
braveheart um
indiana jones
jurassic park uh olive spielberg stuff i
discovered uh my neighbor i grew up
uh in chino hills and my neighbor was
chinese and he's still like my
very best friend he'll be in my wedding
he's my oldest friend and
he showed me
i think he he showed me spirited away
um oh that's a good one yep and then i
think he was also the one to show me
steven chow
i don't quite remember but stephen chow
he made kung fu hustle and he's like
my favorite director oh my god okay
so good
um but stuff like children of men
obviously like what i'm making now is
very much that kind of vibe um right
and
wait what do you say soda
oh my camera's gone
what the heck
all right
let me fix this what about you though
what about you what movies got you into
what you're doing or what inspired you
to get into what you're into right now
um
definitely i mean lord of the rings with
the big one i was i think nine
when that came out in 2001
so uh yeah it's been 20 years since the
fellowship of the ring came out
20 years i feel like it came out like 10
years ago um so that was definitely a
very big defining moment for me like as
a child that blew my socks off um so
that was a big one uh to this day like
the lord of the rings was still my
favorite
trilogy of all time like i watch it in
good times and in bad
rainy sunday afternoons christmas eve
whatever
um like that's to me it's just it's just
a masterpiece of cinematography as well
uh music alone
uh it's just oh god it just chills every
time
so that was a big one and of course like
growing up i loved halo so like you know
that kind of i you know as a teenager i
love games um what teenage boy doesn't
um and i you know i think that's kind of
what got me into the actual border 3d
side of things
um
just because like hey like how would i
met how would i model master chief in 3d
right so you did some digging like okay
like oh 3ds max okay gotta learn that
and then you know just kind of jump into
maya and just slowly started figuring
out like hey you know maybe maybe you
can make a living off of this right and
my obviously my parents were not
convinced they weren't against it but
they were just like huh making video
game for a living are you sure really
really that that
that thing can you can can you actually
do that
um
and uh yeah no i'd say like lord of the
rings and halo were definitely my the
biggest influencers for me
uh it's awesome funny enough like i've
never been much of a movies guy like
don't get me wrong love movies but
growing up we didn't really watch much
movies like my parents were just not
moviegoers they didn't have
i think they upgraded to dvd from vhs
when blu-ray had been out for like five
or six years uh-huh so yeah
yeah so they were like movies were
definitely not a big thing in our
household so like i definitely didn't uh
grow up around movies which is funny
uh you know when i working in the film
industry um and like
you're gonna probably have to cancel the
stream now because i've never actually
seen terminator
oh man you've never seen terminator i
haven't i saw the matrix for the first
time like two or three years ago
oh man what did you say yeah i'm like
mike my level of culture when it comes
to films is
virtually non-existent
well hold on what did you think of the
matrix
i liked it i mean hold up
oh yeah even like 20 years later it
holds up i was surprised like the vfx
they're like i'm like you know what this
is not terrible it's not the best cgi
i've seen but
it it holds up
so uh yeah no i liked it it was great
that's crazy yeah i showed the matrix to
a friend for the first time about yeah
two to three years ago and i was like it
was the best to watch a movie with
someone who
is watching it for the first time
because it's kind of like i get to watch
it for the first time
yep oh so good man
so freaking good
yeah you gotta watch terminal
terminator uh yeah i i i need to and i
mean i saw indiana jones for the first
time with it like
two months ago
what yeah yeah you wanted to be an
archaeologist you had no idea who
indiana
i think it's one of those things where i
grew up pretty sheltered my parents like
oh no like there's nazis in here this is
too violent for you
oh man
and then like i grew up in you know and
kind of never got around to it it's not
because i didn't want to it's just like
ah whatever
yeah and um
yeah no it was great i mean i'm i'm kind
of pissed of my parents for not having
shown me that because i would have loved
it as a kid yeah man like no i would
that would have been perfect that's
such a good movie and i can obviously
it's old right it's very an old style of
filmmaking like you can't make movies
like that anymore
um
but i liked it
yeah it's it's super solid amazing stuff
and like that's what i aspire to do
james cameron is oh man james cameron
he's never really made a bad movie
not i mean uh
say what you will about avatar i'm
it wasn't a bad movie i just didn't it
wasn't my cup of tea
i mean that's fair enough that's fair
enough um i think i saw avatar like
three times in theaters just because
like the cgi blew me away and that was
right around the time where i was like
studying like i was in school for 3d and
i'm like wow this is so cool
um so i was more enamored with the
technical side of it less so
the actual film side of it that makes
sense 100 yeah 100.
are you looking on your scene right now
just now at the time where i need to put
some gak in there and just get some
stuff and just noise it up and you know
put some more crap on the ground and
it's that part where i just need more
detail i'm really bummed out that the
runtime virtual texturing didn't work
that would have been cool to show off
but uh
yeah i just need to put some stuff and
yeah just noise it up
100 i'm kind of like at that point right
now i'm gonna go two angles on it i
think i'm gonna go up to like a
another shot where you actually see the
ground so i'm gonna need to spice it up
a little bit there too
nice
hmm
this is really fun doing amazing man
oh yeah likewise
you're gonna know it's always fun to
like no i was just gonna say like what
would your um
i know you had like your fair share of
struggle when you were using unreal for
the first time and what would you say
your biggest struggle was
um
uh
knowing what to do to make my scene look
photo real
right because there's like a million
things that i could do to make it look
photo real um and i had
no idea what to do there like i had
at first there was zero idea and then
there was some idea but there was there
was like 20 things that you could do and
it was deep in menus and stuff um so it
was just a big mystery
and then i came across
um
who was the first channel that like
i started watching some of like the
unreal engine
tutorials and training and that yeah
that actually helped a lot um
[Music]
there's a guy caves rd
who
uh matt newell
who's incredible incredible uh i think
i'm gonna have him we're gonna try and
get him on the stream next uh next month
okay
he does these cool like photo experience
games in unreal where everything's going
real you're going to have the camera
all right
so like i would just
try and find things that looked
as good as i wanted to make the things
that i wanted to make so the pixel
rebirth um memories of australia
you know
and then i came across your channel and
that was everything
that i needed that was like finally
someone is making the exact tutorials
that i need so if y'all are trying to
learn unreal engine and want to make
your stuff look good check out williams
channel it's in the description all the
stuff is in the description
um
it's not that good he's lying he's lying
oh man like you you know you're just
being nice of course of course being
nice and that's why uh
i don't know it's a good thing it's a
very good thing
but man um
i'm now now i'm rambling what were you
saying you were saying what is the one
thing that took me forever okay yeah no
just one because i like getting an idea
of like what a lot of newcomers struggle
with just because that just gives me
ideas for more content right and uh so
like because like at this point i've
been using unreal for so long that like
i don't
always
see things from the the same perspective
of a of a newcomer right
and i think that for that like i have
some students now uh because i'm doing
and teaching in an online school
called cg spectrum and they have it
they're basically like a mentorship uh
school really awesome school
and um i have a student you know ask me
questions like oh man like that is so
basic i hadn't even considered talking
about that in the lesson
like it just it's so basic to me it's
just second nature and it it's not that
you know they're not idiots for not
knowing it's more the fact that i didn't
even it never crossed my mind to talk
about that because
i i don't even think about myself when i
do it it's just so second nature to me
now uh so it's really it's really nice
when students ask me hey like you kind
of glossed over this section real fast
like oh man no i'm so sorry you're
absolutely right
so um it's always nice to get like a
fresh perspective on things
yeah absolutely 100 percent you know i
overthink things a lot of the time uh
and and take things for granted too
certain pieces of information for
granted so that that's that's a big one
for sure
yeah there's so much content out there
now and it's the problem it's really
hard to find to sort through the weeds
and figure out like what's good and
what's bad and what works for you
because a lot of the content like might
have been like really good at first um
but you know as time goes sometimes like
the software changes and that content is
now outdated or irrelevant or just plain
wrong and it's not that they're you know
they're a bad content creator like this
has happened to me on several of my
videos where i
cover like hey this is how you fix xyz
and then you know they fixed the problem
or something or
they you know did some things were
changed or the console variable changed
or something uh so it's like ah it's
like i i've always wondered like should
i go ahead and like delete that video or
not like it might be helpful for some
people so
it's uh
sometimes people are just wrong that
happens but also sometimes creators you
know the program changes
so yeah yeah 100 100
especially with unreal where things just
change so quickly it's like ridiculously
fast
uh how how fast things change it's
to version uh they'll make some things
way way way different and you know some
right down to the way that some
materials are handled like doing glass
for example handling the refraction on
glass changed from one version to the
next and so values that were correct in
426 are now totally different in 427 so
yeah it's uh it's frustrating sometimes
to kind of keep up and you can't just
edit the video you either have to remove
the video and make a new one or you know
just
yeah or put a pin comment or something
or
yeah yeah yeah i think a pinned comment
is probably
probably the way to go because you put
so much effort into the vid you can't
just take it down
but yeah no i i guess not but unless
it's just blatantly wrong you know but
i've never ran into that so that's an
interesting like concept i
that's definitely interesting yeah
um
so we probably have
10 more minutes let's put 10
solid minutes into
yep
uh into our scene here
cool as focused as we can get yes
um and then we'll we'll call it we'll
export and uh
and then we'll hop into the art review
and sounds good to me
announce some winners here yeah
of my questions are all different from
students are always like mostly lighting
related to because i think lighting is
it's definitely one of the most
underrated
things
ever like sometimes i'll have to kind of
gloss over the lighting part of it you
know did they finish their model and
they finished the character their
texture did you want to show it off
posted to our station they just you know
throw a million lights in there and just
it's it's so
it's such a bummer when you see like an
amazing model that's just poorly lit
it's such a letdown because the lighting
is so important uh it can make
the worst good lighting can make the
worst model look photo real or make the
best possible model look like complete
trash it's 100
don't underestimate lighting and what's
what's interesting though is that
lighting in real life is exactly the
same thing as lighting
in cg it's like the fundamentals of
lighting are exactly the same like
getting soft light it's only a matter of
getting a large light source if that's
all it is like you see here like the the
lighting under my pickup truck is nice
and soft that's just because i have a
huge light source above it the larger
your source of light the softer your
shadows will be and the smaller your
light source let's say just a tiny point
light your shadow will be really hard
and that's why like in the middle of a
midday in l.a in a parking lot the you
know hot summer day the shadows are very
hard very sharp because you know the sun
is it's a tiny dot in our sky right yes
the sun itself is a large light source
but it's so far away
relative to us that it's in the sky it's
just a small dot right so
um that and whereas an overcast day
shadows are nice and soft because our
entire sky
is our light source
so
that's what caused those soft shadows so
it's just when you understand the
concept of how to get those
sharp and soft shadows things really
start
um coming together
yeah agreed and like
the more you study as an artist the more
you study light the better you're gonna
be as an artist um and you know in my
last video i recommended that if you are
a 3d artist
um even a 2d artist
uh
go out and get into photography a little
bit take some pictures i was just about
to say that
yeah
um
because i know you love shooting
photography as well right oh yeah
that's very helpful i would say i'm
almost a photographer first and like 3d
art a second like
i love it um
and what's nice about photography is
that the barrier of entry is really low
like anyone with a phone can go out and
take pictures i recommend that you go
get an actual dedicated camera it
doesn't need to be a super fancy new
mirrorless camera but like get some old
dslr or something and shoot manual and
i promise you your work as a 3d artist
will drastically improve
uh if you pick up photography
i agree 100 man
it's uh it gets you out of your office
so that's that's one nice thing it
forced you to take a break from the
screen
um
and you know it just it allows you to do
something different while doing
something relatively similar as well at
the end of the day we're creating images
right
and
understanding how light works how
composition worked how cameras work
because you know we're working with
cameras right now uh directly in unreal
right so
you know learning how a camera works in
real life will really help you
understand how light works in cg and in
real life it all comes together really
nicely eventually those puzzle pieces
are really just gonna it's just gonna
click in your head you're like oh
okay i get it
yup absolutely agreed it translates
perfectly
what do you shoot with tony right
oh yeah i love sony
let me make good stuff the a7r ii
cool
cool
same for yourself
uh no i shoot nikon so i've been
shooting with nikon d800 for many years
and i just got a nikon z62
uh recently so i'm pretty invested in
nikon glass so staying with nikon just
made sense
nice
yeah it's when you get the lenses you
know it's like
you're kind of locked in
uh yeah pretty much especially once
you've got start getting like thousands
and thousands of dollars of lenses like
yeah i mean i could sell them uh but i
mean i love my lenses like some of these
like my 85 1.4 it's just
it's a marvel of engineering and i think
it just creates beautiful
fi i can't sell it i it would it breaks
my heart yeah
all right
um what's going on with the camera is it
overheating
sony
sorry oh no don't start
it's like
turning off for some reason
that's annoying
thank you soto we got sotomonte behind
the scenes
talking and i'm whispering into my ear
all the things i need to know
much appreciated
thank you sotomonte
every time every time i have a stream
something goes wrong every time man like
you can't help it you really
really can't help it you spend hours
like planning for every single
contingency and uh it's still managing
the budget yes
dang i need some like vents and grills
like i could spend a lot more time on
this
so one thing i do recommend to people
especially when you're working with
large light sources like you have on my
screen here
don't
necessarily just use like a big plane
with a white emissive texture on it you
want to get a little bit of
a tiny little bit of detail in there and
what i mean by this is let's take a look
at the reflections on this truck
notice how i've got like a ramp in it so
it's brighter in the middle and it's a
bit darker in the outer corners
right around here and that's just
because in my texture itself i'm using a
um let me find find it here
this is my texture that i'm using on
these planes so it's actually a picture
of a soft box that i took
and so it's a 16-bit image and so it
kind of gets like this this kind of
texture in it um let me make it full
screen to see and this is what i'm using
as my light so you do get a little bit
of variation in there because light is
not just a purely evenly lit white plane
not a pure white plane right and so
getting a tiny little bit of like you
know shadow detail just some slight
parts are brighter some parts that are
darker um that's how a softbox works in
real life like if you have a fluorescent
tube
that is behind like a
a like an acrylic white panel like this
you're going to get some hot spots
you're going to get some parts that are
brighter than others some parts that are
a little bit darker it's going to be
very uneven
and so that really makes a big
difference when you're trying to achieve
some photorealism uh it's not so
noticeable right here
but if you look into reflections and
stuff you kind of get that kind of uh
that unevenness it's not like perfectly
white
that's a problem right there
it definitely helps a lot which is
getting that
paying attention
especially when you're working with
shiny objects the reflection become
almost more important than the object
itself um we were working on a show once
where we had a very shiny new porsche we
had it was like a it was a full cgi
porsche and you know we had we got the
model from triplet from the client and
the look that was great but the problem
is like we actually it was a close-up of
the car
but we had to spend like a week or two
modeling the entire scene that wasn't
even on camera okay because it wasn't
even in the frame because we had to
model everything so it would show up in
the reflections of the car oh my god
dude no
so
that's just kind of it's one of those
things like with reflections it's really
important that the reflections look good
but yeah that was uh that was a bit of a
bummer
oh cool we have the car you know it
fills in the frame that's gonna be a
very quick and easy shot to light and ha
it was not
so you couldn't do an hdri in that case
uh no because you don't get the same
parallax because the car was moving
those reflections moving and stuff so
it's an hdri wouldn't have worked
perfectly now
so we had it we also had it wasn't a
full cg shot it was a car that we had to
implement into a live-action plate so it
had to match
the environment around it for
uh consistency with the other shots so
gotcha
yeah it was uh it was a lot of work
it's the most time you ever spent on a
shot
a one shot
yeah
about a month maybe
yeah it it depends on the shot like it
just because sometimes you have like a
lot of modeling to do and stuff and uh
yeah if you have a lot of assets to
create that can i mean that can be like
six months plus um but if you're if you
already have the assets you need to
integrate something into the plate
that can that's usually a little bit
faster for sure
i i've actually almost enjoyed working
in film more than uh than in games
because in games like
the thing that's discouraging about
working in games is you know you could
spend a month working on this amazing
character it's a really nice looking
environment and then at the end of
production you know programmers come
along like hey we need to optimize we
need more frames
and they like make all those textures go
from like nice 4k texture to like oh
this is a 512 texture
no what are you doing ruining my art ah
that's brutal
it is it it's just heartbreaking
that that's uh whereas in film like we
don't care you're using like five you
know 18
4k udems or whatever it doesn't matter
doesn't matter as long as it looks good
that's all that counts 100 percent
are you working you haven't worked in
games yourself right you're you're
mostly in uh
doing teaching
yeah uh
filming editing shooting
uh vfx 3d yeah all for
like live action stuff um nice
never made a game in my life
don't really have
an intention to make one though i like
video games are what inspire me to make
movies
right a lot of the time
um yep
but
yeah i don't know maybe maybe one day
maybe i'll make something one day
yeah i mean it's a lot of work it's a
lot of work that a lot of people don't
always realize
yeah
games are not just something you can
just like oh i'm going to make a video
game in six months like well
good
luck
yeah it's nuts like
actually working in unreal gave me such
a better appreciation for games because
i realized all the stuff that literally
like is manually placed everything is
just like manually done like so games
like uh
the last of us
you know oh man that's a work of art
it's insane
or like half life or
any of those kind of games where like
they're all just built out it's crazy
all the systems that are built out i'm
sure they're like reusing things and
automating stuff but
it's nuts
it's so much work i understand why they
cost sixty dollars like
at least you know it's insane
i mean it's a how many billion dollar
industry i'm not sure i don't know
yeah i don't know a lot of billions
probably yeah
come on
all right probably got
two more minutes
get your shots set up
yep
160 billion dollar industry what does
that mean does that mean they made 160
billion dollars in
their lifetime what does that mean
so i mean 160 billion dollars
changed hands in the year
oh my goodness
that's nice that's pretty nuts
there we go i should probably save i i
haven't saved in so long i'm the worst
of saving
oh you don't have auto save
uh
i actually i do but i don't save it i
haven't used auto save and unreal that
much like
it's uh sometimes i do
i heard someone i don't know usually
usually i save often yeah and
yeah it's the worst when you're you were
about to save and then it crashes like i
was i was i was in the process of doing
it
yeah that's brutal
i don't think i have time to get my
second angle like this i thought it
would be more built out but this isn't
going to work
i'd have to put it in fine too let's get
a nice big fill in there and
yeah i got the one angle that i was
going for cool
so
let's get our images
exported and then
well actually here how about this
let's each take two minutes to just talk
about our scene and what we did yep
sure how he did it uh how about
are you ready
uh yeah in the hot seat all right bam
go for it that's beautiful yeah so
thanks uh super simple scene got a car
in there uh a bunch of other crystal
megascans assets the uh just kind of
like the gag the pipes and stuff these
are from a pack that already had
downloaded for another project uh so
that's the beauty of just the
one of the greatest strengths of what
really is its marketplace is that every
single month there's a whole bunch of
free assets like every like i think the
first is the first monday or the first
sunday of every month
they release like
five but anywhere between five and ten
free
assets on the marketplace
really awesome to just you know like oh
this is useful just download that just
download a whole bunch of packs and
and just add it to your project and
that's the beauty of the marketplace
because it's just so all these assets
have just been made for unreal there's
no i don't need to relink textures and
materials or you know when you buy stuff
on turbosquid you know how it is every
time you need to like remake the
material or re-link the texture and then
make your new shaders for it um it's a
super tedious process but with the
unreal marketplace it's just like you
buy it and you add it to your project
and it's ready to go it's really nice
for that um so that's that's basically
what i did here um just had a whole
bunch of assets from different packs
some just some
gak from i should probably shouldn't
have done that i reset my render um you
know just some garbage bags and some
just stuff on the ground some just some
uh rubble and stuff
uh just scattered all around and really
what sells this scene is just lighting
it's just like one nice massive
lit roof um
you don't and sometimes that's all you
need like lighting
this is kind of being all
this is holding together because of like
the cool top down lighting i think that
otherwise it would fall apart if i were
going for a more realistic like typical
parking lot style thing i think that's
like this whole scene would fall apart
it wouldn't hold up um
but i think it's just kind of cool to
have you know just a little bit of depth
of field in there get some that soft
lighting
and call it a day get a cool get a cool
car with a rim light on it and done
so if i if i thank you if i go off and
turn off pass tracing this is my what it
looks like in like real time mode it
looks like trash it's really really bad
so um
yeah like that's the thing the pass
tracer is just it just calculates
everything for you um
it's super easy so that's why i love
using it that's one of the main reasons
i tend to stick with 427 it's just the
path tracer just it just works and if
you don't need
to have a real-time render
go ahead and use the patch tracer it's
great for that so uh it's it kind of
makes it similar to working in blender
or in other any other offline renderer
dang man noted that's insane the
difference on that can you do that one
more time the
difference yeah
the path tracer and just like the real
time i'm just gonna get a different
angle here so i'm just gonna let this
render real quick and then
switch this to lip mode so this is you
know real-time mode uh of course i can
get the real-time mode to look very
similar to how it looks with the patch
tracer um but that wasn't my focus here
i didn't want to spend time doing that
so
this is just
what i did instead and you'll see it's
not a complex scene there's nothing
really fancy happening here four walls
floor ceiling
some pipes on the ceiling and just you
know a doorway over here
and just some crap on the ground and
that's it the rest the
the shot doesn't this angle doesn't look
as good just because it's not as nice a
composition right um if i go back to
where i was you know this this whole
shot works a lot better because there's
more stuff happening right the the
you know we got the pillars kind of we
got those leading lines in there we got
a bit more depth to the scene
so it's it's this whole shot is looks a
little bit less terrible mainly thanks
to depth of field composition and
lighting and the actual asset work is
nothing impressive the environment work
is nothing impressive but you know it
kind of holds up
it definitely holds up it's it's awesome
so freaking cool thanks
um
all right so
yeah my camera my camera is like
dying maybe i'll uh oh no let it charge
up i don't know does that work like that
who knows so
yeah
that's awesome
scene um
is
basically what is it f yeah f11 here we
go
so this scene
is very similar it's just a lot of top
lit soft lighting
uh can't go wrong with soft lighting it
just ah
it's the best the best
yeah it's the absolute best i would
certainly do a number of things here to
a little bit differently i'm not really
the biggest fan is a ladder asset right
now
i wanted to throw in some like flood
lights
here on the side um but this is all like
my texture my concrete texture pack
um
that i put together so i'm excited that
that's working um
yeah um i just put a bunch of
cubes in my scene and
threw down the texture sky is your sky
just cubes or that like fog or something
you put in there i i do have um
exponential height fog in the scene okay
cool cool yeah so that's set to like
point three um
and i just had this infinite extent
going up uh
some sort of pathway here this is
heavily inspired by
his name's joe nishizawa he's a
photographer in japan and he takes
photos of like
sewer systems and all this stuff and
there's a there's a shot
very similar to this of them lowering a
truck into a sewer system and it looks
literally it looks like this um
and yeah of course you got depth of
field a little chain in the foreground
um some pipes that probably need some
more modeling and
you know but i'm happy with it i like it
i think it it's really fun to just like
place these pieces in here and uh
and is my screen from getting some some
dune vibes here
oh yeah you know just saw that so i'm
like
all amped on that of course yeah kind of
got the earthy tone there
yeah
it works well
yeah absolutely
um so yeah that that's it let me see if
i can get my camera going here and then
we'll go over the
weekly
art review or the weekly so many words
at this point i'm not i'm making half
sense
um the weekly challenge winners we got
five winners to announce let's see if my
camera can survive
all uh
all of these challenge winners okay so
um
[Music]
how are we gonna do this this is the
first time that i'm streaming with soda
monte on my other computer
so here's what we're gonna do so i know
you can hear me we're gonna switch over
here
to art review
and we're gonna essentially go through
these
and announce the winners uh the prompt
was
minimal
so since
how am i going to do this basically
sodamonte once i
go on to the next piece of art you're
going to need to
uncheck the art itself so that the name
remains there
and then i can pull up the second piece
of art if that makes sense
we'll uh yeah
all right so here we go the first winner
of the weekly challenge
minimal is
weekend with this
awesome piece here a little smokestack
situation very beautiful render you got
the birds in there it's very subtle
very minimal i love the colors uh
william can you see that
yeah again looks great i've heard i
thought it was a photo
yeah yeah it looks great it's super
solid um
probably did a little comping of the
steam in photoshop or after effects or
something i would assume but
that looks darn good so weekend
congratulations on winning the challenge
winner roll
this week you got the whole discord
server opening up for you very good
stuff congratulations
all right so the next
winner we got five to announce
um
so sotomonta if you could just hide that
picture
and then i like
exactly perfect
the next winner is
visual one of the mods actually but
there is no rule against mods winning
challenges if their art is sick it all
comes down to the art here
um and i absolutely love what you put
together here um
very very beautiful
very simple i love the cut out legs and
arms and stuff in the color palette the
lighting everything's great
yeah this is awesome i like the i love
the stylized look i'm a sucker for
stylized stuff like we see so much
photoreal stuff every day we're like
inundated with it and of course don't
get me wrong i love that stuff too um
but it's really nice to see
some fresh stylized stuff in there as
well
absolutely yeah super cool congrats
visual good stuff as always
uh moving on number three
we have
something stupid now i don't know if
that's your discord name
or if that's just what you named your
piece of art
but you gotta believe in yourself a
little bit more i think this is really
nice
it looks freaking great um i love the
painterly vibes to it it's very simple
and it's just playing with light like
you're saying william it's all about the
lighting
it is 100
like you don't even need the model to be
all that good when you've got good
lighting to make up for it
100 i think it's a really solid
example of that right here very very
simple very subtle it looks awesome
super soft i like it
yeah
um so congratulations you got the
challenge winner roll this week
hang on to it keep doing the challenges
uh you might get it next week
number four
we have
one dead duck and this
was done in unreal engine uh wanda doug
just started using unreal i think unreal
five yeah and uh
you know he's going to town he wins
these a lot um
and i freaking dig the composition it's
an original piece
uh
very similar to what we were doing you
know it has the industrial vibe the
concrete and everything but what do you
think of this one
i like it said the competition is top
notch i think this is i mean this would
make a great photo let alone a render um
if i didn't know any better like if you
were like looking at this like really
low red from afar like you know i would
on someone's wall like that would be a
beautiful photograph um belongs in a
museum it's uh it's really rare to see
cg artists that have such a good knack
for photography as well
there's a lot of great cg artists out
there but it's really rare to see people
make those two art forms together
yeah
yeah agreed and that's what i love so
much about it is like
how close can you get it to look like a
like a photo can you trick people with
it
and it's still stylized somewhat
obviously but i still love like the the
the composition is so strong here that
it could be a photo um it it looks
wonderful i absolutely love this i'm not
even normally a fan of black and white
images but this is this is great
yep totally works do you know um
fonho
the photographer no i don't
oh man yeah definitely check out faunho
he's a i think he's a chinese
photographer i think he's past at this
point but he took he's famous for his
like black and white photos of hong kong
okay they're just insane
um which this is probably inspired by i
would i would have to guess um
but okay moving on to the last one one
did congratulations once again you got
the challenge winner roll
um number five
our last challenge winner and then we
have some honorable mentions today to
get into because
i think it's worth it y'all y'all do
good stuff and i want to make sure you
guys get the credit for it so number
five we have mitch mitch with this one
um
went for a different approach to the
minimal
uh prompt i love this it is very clean
very very clean i love the symmetrical
framing the colors are beautiful
um
i i i'm such a huge fan of this
it's it's so weird but i dig it
it's definitely like it's not something
you'd see every day this is really it's
quite original
yeah yeah absolutely it reminds me of
something
like psa or some some weird like no
smoking yeah thing or
yeah no definitely i yeah i'm a fan what
is this rendered in
mitch mitch i don't know soto do you
know is it blender
uh i think it's blender if i doesn't
really matter i think it looks great
yeah it doesn't really matter that's a
yeah a great point doesn't really matter
um but super solid so congrats to the
challenge winners we just have a couple
uh honorable mentions so sotomante i'm
gonna need you to keep that up there
and then
turn off that piece of art and then
you'll have to toggle them on because
we basically have soda multi tapped
parsec into my other computer that i
can't see right now
um and if you could just tell me the
names of the people so i can relay them
as well because i can't see them the
screen's too tiny
blenderian
yeah okay so we got this one here
looking really nice you've seen these
before like your classic
simple minimalistic bedroom lit really
nicely looks like you can touch it
very beautiful very good stuff
um
shout outs to you next up
um
who is it
dg dg abs digi abs
uh this one is just darn satisfying
oh that would make such a good nft
yeah
i want this on my on my uh
on my desktop i feel like the one thing
with this one though is like i would
love to see the water just a bit more
vibrant and blue and then like
if like moss some green moss collected
on the on these little like pyramids or
something that'd be pretty sweet but
um
i dig it oh yeah no dude i yeah i love
this so i love those satisfying
simulations that you see a lot of these
days ah it's so good
yeah you just go down the rabbit hole
with that one um
really nice stuff did you abs congrats
next up
frizzler
that right yeah so this one's really
cool
i love the idea
if you can't guess already
it's going to form something it's uh low
poly face oh that's cool
yeah it the the
render quality is fantastic my only
gripe with it is the um the handheld
camera motion it's just a little a
little much
but it is hand animated which is pretty
sweet
um
just a little too shaky for me i think
you can tone it down just a little bit
but
this is beautiful absolutely beautiful
great idea
great render
i like it
yeah
jack the hack is next
very nice
reminds me of the thing have you seen
the thing william
i have not actually
shame on me i know
i'll add it to the list
yeah it's amazing good stuff but yeah
this is very
very subtle i dig it
um
low poly character went with like the
different approach to minimal that's the
minimal polis
i love it yeah good stuff jack
who's next
joel yes
oh that's life yeah very peaceful
i could see myself sitting in the living
room there with a hot cup of coffee
100 maybe a little telescope looking at
the ocean
ah so good
yeah yeah those toned i love the colors
the great color palette right there
100 good design too nice silhouettes
sweet good stuff joel that that focus
rack is great
yeah
i mean
oh we got our very own mdk up next i
love this one this one came very very
close to winning um this is so freaking
cool to me
yeah that's another side of trying one
yep and it loops too
no does it
it's such a
reaction
it's so good i love it
it's seamless it's freaking perfect
man i think my mind would break trying
to make something seamless like that i'd
be like but wait huh
but that [ __ ] what
yep
yup
very very i'd have to try i've never
tried being a seamless animation like
that before but
it's probably not as bad as it seems but
gavin shapiro
has he's the guy who does like those
penguins
the looping like penguin animations uh
right and flamingos
man he has a great
uh it's an hour-long
talk on maxon's like 3d motion show
and i think it was like last year or
something uh okay and he goes into how
he does his loops and i learned so much
from that he really makes it seem simple
um uh yeah i'll definitely check that
out what was it called again his name is
gavin shapiro and it's the maxon 3d
motion show
3d motion got it yeah and anyone can
learn from that doesn't matter what
program you're using
um
up next
what we got
obliviart
very dark
no kidding oh that's my kind of humor i
like it
yeah leave the job quit the job and uh
just
walk down as far as you can go that's
rough
god
uh i dig it though it's clean looks nice
i dig it
yeah good stuff obliviart
who do we got next
pogipski or something like that
uh
very simple
very very simple an apology it's on the
names here i just can't see it's so tiny
i'm like we're figuring out the workflow
but uh
this is beautiful i love the very simple
uh setup here but it comes down to that
lighting
yeah
it's always lighting every time
mm-hmm
yep beautiful beautiful catching that
shuttle that subtle red light there
really makes the the whole thing
100
very very good stuff
uh next up i think there's two more
who's this by
slate oh i like this i want this on my
desk
yes
yes yeah the light again the lighting
the lighting composition framing top
notch
very very good stuff slate congrats for
the honorable mention and i think is
this the last one
ajinka z
um
freaking awesome you know totally looks
like a poster uh i'd put this up on my
wall
very beautiful love the colors on this
yeah same thing i i totally agree it
again it's all fitting
composition yeah we've said it like
20-20 times throughout the stream but
it's just it's just a testament to how
powerful it can be
absolutely
um so congrats to everybody congrats to
the challenge winners um this week's
theme is uh is industrial so you have
until i believe friday at 9 00 a.m
pacific standard time to get your
submissions in
it's all on the discord the link is in
the description
um
william dude thank you so much for doing
this with us um this is mine it's an
honor to not only be here
you we did it i love everything you i
love everything you kind of put together
like the community you built over time
it's nothing short of inspirational for
you know other creators like myself you
know people who are new to youtube in
general like i think you're one of the
the people that a lot of other creators
that i know uh kind of look up to
um
[Music]
on youtube in this industry so keep up
what you're doing
much appreciated man and if people want
to learn unreal engine
please
go to williams channel the link is in
the description we also have his
instagram twitter we got your art
station in there too go check them out i
know you all become a fan immediately
um i know we got a lot of fans up in
here
um as well so we got to have you back at
some point thank you for
taking the time we went for i don't know
three and a half hours or so uh yeah
something like that i kind of lost track
of time yeah no it's all good that's the
the best uh
that's a good kind of losing track of
time i like it
absolutely man all right well hey you
have a good evening um you'd thanks yeah
and you enjoy your rock climbing today
oh my god i can't wait it's going to be
good
all right peace out all right man thank
you much have a good day later
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you